well good morning to everybody
we'd like to welcome the public uh to
this meeting of the education committee
here in the house uh I trust everybody
had a good Memorial Day
I did walking in the parade and standing
in the Sun and almost having a heat
stroke
it was 90 degrees up in Haverhill oh
and
yes it is really a hot one it's a corker
so just a little information about what
we got going on today
um we have uh one bill which has three
non-germain amendments so each one of
those non-germaine amendments will have
a separate hearing before us it's on
Bill HB one uh 136 this is a bill which
uh has a totally different topic it's
prohibiting the employment of
volunteering or revoked a revoked or
suspended
teacher or educator and and so this is
totally different the bills are all
about the FAFSA
so uh that's what we will be doing first
we'll be walking through each one of
those uh hearings and then following
that we'll go into executive session and
most likely I'm sure there will be a
brief caucus uh prior to going into that
we have several bills which we have to
uh complete
once we're done that process and I'll
I'll introduce our subs here in a second
uh once we're
done that process we are going to be
looking at our retained bills and some
folks are thinking are you going to be
acting on any of those bills the answer
is no we will not take any action on
retaining bills today we're simply
trying to identify which of those bills
really need subcommittee work and has
potential for moving forward and with
that we would like to try to nail it
down to where we're going to have these
subcommittees and then the remaining
bills which we don't you know put in the
subcommittee will be dealing with a
committee of the whole later on this
coming fall those reports have be out by
November so we have a lot of time on the
retain stuff so but this is not a
meeting in the afternoon where we're
going to be actually taking action the
other thing I will speak to in the
afternoon as we I have several bills
have come back to the Senate that are
requesting either that we concur
non-concur or request committee a
conference I always work with the whole
Committee in trying to determine which
direction we're going to recommend and
so we'll be looking at those bills and I
have side by sides and each those bills
for committee members which will be able
to look at
and the other item I'd like to talk
about today is where we are with our
education funding
uh in in the state here for adequacy
quite an interesting executive session I
attended on Friday
and I'd like to get into the nuts and
bolts of the changes of that particular
plan that's coming forth out of the
Senate compared to that which we had
presented in hp2 from the house a lot of
real changes there so with that that's
our docket for today how we're going to
treat things looking at around the table
here I can see a lot of the faces which
are not normal or not normal I see one
face excuse that that that that yeah
that might be myself too
um uh representative grassy of course
has been on education prior to any of us
and so representative grassy is over to
my left ear right
um he will be here in place of
reps on Woodcock he didn't want to come
down with Conway today too much fun up
there and then going on to this side
represent cascadden is not here right
now but she will be here she will be
here she had an appointment and so she
will be coming in closer to 11 o'clock
so that that'll be fine going down that
side we have uh Colonel Moffett I
understand you turned 35 today
uh it is my birthday yes uh Mr chair
happy to be here where the action is
yeah and representative on S education
before so uh welcome back going down on
that side representative Heath has also
been on education before which is
wonderful and and she has been here
present many times this year and welcome
back Mary
coming around the table I don't see any
faces until we all represent this the
Simone as a decimoni or D Simone Issa
Monique I thought so I got I won the
best guy
so uh she has also been here as a son
before and welcome and representative
Murray
have you been here once before yeah and
welcome back yeah so with that we have
our subs here in place and we're going
to start right out with our our hearing
for today the first hearing on the
non-germaine on 136 I'd like to open
that up uh we have a pink card here from
representative Noble who is presenting
that um Amendment welcome
good morning everybody I'm Kristen Noble
and I represent Hillsborough District 2
the town of Bedford
I'm bringing this amendment
1396h forward to repeal RSA 193 colon
26-a the FAFSA graduation requirement on
behalf of my constituent superintendent
Michael Fournier of the Bedford school
district as well as many of his
colleagues from around the state
the reason why this is coming up now is
because this law will take effect on
July 1st of this year
for those who weren't here like myself
let me give you some background in 2021
as part of a senate Omnibus Bill we
passed a law that required the free
application for financial student aid or
FAFSA be filled out as a high school
graduation requirement or the student
can obtain a waiver
the intent was that requiring everyone
to complete the FAFSA could possibly
reveal to some students that they could
afford College by qualifying for the
Pell Grant loans or other financial aid
from a school
the thought was that this would open the
door for many more students to earn
college degrees
when you fill out the FAFSA you must
list at least one school that you want
your financial information sent to
prior to filling out the application a
student would have already done the
research on schools and likely already
applied
it's also not a complete picture of
whether a student can afford College
if a student can't pay for college on
their own they'll be applying for
scholarships and Loans in addition to
any Aid that they might get
so my point is if the student has the
desire to go to college then they are
filling out the FAFSA without it being
mandated by the state
if a student doesn't already have
college goals then they shouldn't be
mandated to fill it out
RSA 193 colon 26-a says the district
shall provide each high school student
or their parents support or assistance
needed to comply
high school guidance counselors in this
state already do their very best to help
repair college-bound students and that
includes help with the FAFSA
there are countless resources outside of
school to help students and parents with
the FAFSA
the law states that the FAFSA or waiver
is a prerequisite to receiving a high
school diploma
but there's really no teeth here because
if a student has fulfilled all other
graduation requirements then they can't
really be stopped from graduating it
says the principal would have to attest
that they made a good faith effort to
assist the student with either the FAFSA
or the waiver
so if the law can't be enforced is there
really a need
one of the biggest arguments in favor of
Medicaid direct certification was that
districts wouldn't have the hassle of
chasing after free and reduced lunch
paperwork this also requires the
districts to chase applications and
waivers for hundreds of students
while this requirement may work just
fine for other states this is not the
New Hampshire way it's an invasion of
privacy it's an overstep by the state
for both the individual and our school
districts it sends the wrong message to
students that college is the best
pathway but for many students it's not
and that's okay
this is not to say the FAFSA is an
important it certainly is which is why
our districts already provide
information to students and their
families
I know there are some that think that
let's just wait and see how it goes but
I trust that these superintendents know
how this will impact their districts
they're asking for your support in
repealing the RSA so I have a letter
here that um several of the
superintendents have signed
so I'm just going to read to you the
districts
um that signed it
Bedford Goffstown and New Boston Nashua
Manchester Hollis and Brookline Pelham
Sunapee Hopkinton bow and Dunbarton
Berlin Merrimack Conway cursarge Exeter
and surrounding towns Bethlehem and
surrounding towns keen and surrounding
towns Guilford Lebanon Hillsboro Deering
Alton and Barnstead Henniker where and
Stoddard
and that's it so my actually I'll
explain my Amendment really quick it's
very simple it just repeals the law
including the reporting requirement
thank you very much are there questions
uh representative Noble
representative cordelli thank you thank
you for presenting your Amendment
um you mentioned the uh
uh principal could attest that they've
made a good for a good faith effort to
uh do either the the waiver or the um
FAFSA application
um who do they attest to and what
happens
I have no idea two okay I don't know so
that that I wasn't able to find like any
technical advisory from the doe or
anything like that so there's many
questions in here that I have but thank
you
thank you further question
representative Hall
thank you and thank you for taking my
question could you read the bottom line
sentence from the letter from the
superintendents
you know the oh I did not I didn't read
their letter
but is there a a sentence in that letter
that you could read to us you know you
didn't look at it at all
I didn't look at it at all do you have
copies I have copies I'm going to hang
out all right thank you okay are there
further questions from the committee
oops yes
thank you very much Mr chair
um so in the in the nutshell what was
the um superintendent's objection to uh
to the current policy
so
it's probably best to ask them and I
have it all in the letter uh a lot of
what is what I mentioned it's an
invasion of privacy
um State shouldn't be and enforcing this
on families
um and also it it could potentially be a
burden on the district so follow up on
that go ahead I I I did hear you say it
was an invasion of privacy I was
wondering if you could be more specific
as to why it's Invasion privacy
because they're trying to force you to
to share your financial information
and a follow-up on it sharing it with
who
with whom well this would be shared with
the federal government
and that Finance another question
try to get your point out yeah no thanks
thanks and that that financial
information is information that that
comes from internal revenue
um right so potential which is part of
the federal government right ready so
potentially it could also be shared with
the school so if we're asking
the school to help parents fill this out
you're you're sharing your information
with them as well
no all right and I I don't I'm what's
very unclear to me is how do they
how do they even know whether you filled
it out or not because a lot of times
this is done online
so I don't know if they're if you're
supposed to hand them the form
yeah I think there'll be an answer to
that coming up okay I think there will
be a lot of answers as we have other
people presenting here yes represent
Balboni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um at the beginning of it you said it
was important um because it goes into
effect so it has I'm sorry because I
don't know what's happened yet
um has this gone into effect yet nope it
was past two years ago but it goes into
effect July 1st of this year
so
so if it hasn't gone into effect how do
we know that there's a problem with it
well I'm trusting that the
superintendents can foresee the issues
that they'll have with this
thank you thank you
further questions yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question regarding the the
Privacy issue
um would you agree that the IRS says
certain standards in place for releasing
financial information generally
yes and if I may follow up on that
um would you then also agree that by
sharing that information more widely
than just the IRS the Department of
Education it may uh contribute to more
eyes seeing that and possibly increasing
the risk of data breaches yes thank you
further questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much could
you make sure we get copies of that
letter immediately thank you
okay I'd like to uh welcome honorable
Jay Khan
welcome
thank you
I too is it a Memorial Day Parade an
event yesterday uh
thank you for uh recognizing me thank
you committee for allowing me to testify
um
uh some background New Hampshire
graduates 15 000 high school students
every year
uh our in-state FAFSA completion rate
currently is 50 percent
50 percent
uh there's a whole range and you can go
look on the websites and find them
there's a whole range a lot of schools a
lot of states are at uh 80 70 60 percent
in fact if you look at New England you
can see who's winning the race
and I suggest you go to the federal
student aid site and look up
Massachusetts and look up the gis map
and you will see all the surrounding
states around Massachusetts
and you can see why they're winning the
race
why are companies relocating there when
the there's
plenty of opportunity to relocate in New
Hampshire well it's because they've got
the educated Workforce and they are
completing FAFSA forms at 60 and 70
percent
uh
our school districts they range all over
the place averages are averages right
and you have some schools that are down
to 35 percent you're going to have other
schools that are up at 80 percent if
you're up at 80 you won the race
you're doing great
if you're up at 70 you might be but
that's only Bedford
Lebanon
Hopkinton
uh
and Londonderry
uh so
50 percent is the average in our state
at 50 percent completion rate of FAFSA
that means that there are 7 500 students
who are likely going to college or some
post-secondary experience not
necessarily a college
uh
in you know among our graduates on an
annual basis and when you then factor in
representative lead you can verify that
in fact about 58 of our
high school graduates in the state they
wind up going out of state if they're
going to a post-secondary education
experience closer to 60.
and if it is 60
that means that there are less than 3
000 students
who are going from high school into a
post-secondary education experience in
New Hampshire
and that's losing the race
and you can get this data this does not
need to be a swag kind of amendment
in fact this should have been a bill
and I'm surprised that this committee is
considering amendments on this when
there is factual data that you should be
looking at
Now put on your employer hat
if you were to locate anywhere in the
country where would you locate your
business
biotech infotech
Health Sciences
you're going to go where there's an
educated Workforce
this isn't a pro-education or forcing an
education mandate kind of statute
this is a pro business statute
it's about aligning our education system
with the needs of our employers and you
know who those are
they're in the Halls on a regular basis
ask them
what decides
the expansion to a second shift in your
Workforce
why isn't it why is it Albany
manufacturing is down to one shift a day
Workforce
Casa isn't the only basis for fed is not
just the basis for federal financial aid
scholarships it's the basis for
institutional Aid as well
you can reduce the price of a college
education by a third to a half through
the combination of federal and
institutional Aid that means that a
fifty thousand dollar per year cost can
be reduced to twenty five thousand
dollars or a twenty five thousand dollar
price could be reduced to twelve
thousand dollars and you can go on the
websites and you can test any college in
the country and find out what their
actual price is after their discounts
and if you choose to attend a community
college in New Hampshire you could
attend for practically no cost at all
a FAFSA requirement is a pro-family bill
it lowers college debt you begin saving
faster you begin to buy homes and you
can start your family
that is a pro family bill
the result of getting a post-secondary
education credential makes a huge
difference in lifetime earnings we know
this the Community College completer
earns 50 percent more than a high school
degree completer
a bachelor's degree completer earns 100
percent more over their lifetime
this is a pro worker statute
if you're looking at this statute as the
school administrator's burden you are
completely missing the point
a FAFSA requirement is pro-business it's
pro-family and it's Pro Workforce
and it's a pro-state revenue strategy
and if you're basing your opinion on a
school district that already has an 80
FAFSA completion rate you are again
missing the point
this is evidence-based policy and your
decision today should be evidence-based
you measure what's important to you and
the measurements are right in front of
you if you look
if the requirement doesn't work then
change it it's exactly right
and why was it put off until this year
it was put off because
the federal government is simplifying
the form you don't need to reveal family
income it will come from the IRS
it'll be verified that way
the waiver is in place because families
may not want to disclose it
and the Department of Education has done
what it was by Statute asked to do it
has developed a single form for all
districts in the state to use as the
waiver for their families
so I think you lack the evidence to make
the changes that are proposed today
and I hope that the committee will allow
this statute to be put into effect there
are a lot of strategies that have been
worked on
by multiple parties in the state to
implement this statute
and it's ready to roll in this next
school year thank you for the
opportunity to testify thank you very
much representative McDonald thank you
and good morning
if this statute does not go into effect
until July 1st of this year so it has
not gone into effect yet then how can
you be so confident that increasing the
number of students that fill out the
form would increase the number of
students picking New Hampshire over
another state
thanks for asking that question uh
because it is been shown in Louisiana
and Alabama in Illinois
states that have implemented this act
very similar almost exact uh
and they can show the evidence Louisiana
after implementing this over the last
three years
believe it or not is over 80 percent
further questions from the committee
represent Myler
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
could you explain what's on the form
right could you explain what's on the
form
uh well it is under revision
so the form that
I filled out for my kids uh
was about 90 questions
and it drove uh
well somebody helped me Senator
Alexander
uh Lamar Alexander uh it drove him crazy
it was his final act as a U.S senator to
thin down the form and he forced it
through in December of 2020.
and that is now going into effect
July 1.
so as students in this next school year
fill out the form it will be a thin down
25 question that was their goal get to a
25 question form and the reason it can
be thinned down is because they've got
access to IRS records and
that was the whole idea of why to make
the implementation date to coincide with
the federal the the federal government's
implementation of the send down form
foreign
then I'll jump to some of the others um
I recall when you introduced this
Senator honorable Jay Khan to the
committee here uh one of the questions
uh we all had I think at that point in
time everybody believed that the intent
the overall is laudable that students be
familiar there's a FAFSA available
the issue which drew a lot of attention
and a concern was the requirement that
if you want to graduate from high school
you shall that's the way it came to us
complete the FAFSA
it was modified so now if a
superintendent chases down or a
principal chases down
uh an individual that there could be an
exception made have you heard from
either of those states that you talk
about Louisiana or Alabama
are there any students that are not
filling out that FAFSA
that are being held back not graduating
even though they may have completed all
the requirements of an opportunity for
an adequate education
uh they're they're not graduating have
you heard of any of that occurring
because they have that requirement in
their law
I have not and and when the bill came to
this committee uh it had all three of
the options
and that's the way that it's implemented
in law uh in in statute currently the
student completes the FAFSA
option two is that the student or the
family
indicates that the information has been
shared with them uh and choose not to
complete the FAFSA and option three is
that the principal verifies that an
attempt to
notify the student the family of the
FAFSA completion requirement has been
made and uh and and the person has not
uh
complied but but the principal can sign
off that that good faith effort was made
those three components are exactly what
is in those other
what's been implemented in those other
states
uh so and and I'm not familiar with that
that instance and Mr chairman what I saw
in your bill introduced this last year
with the requirements for a high school
or for a student
education in the state is financial
literacy and I I appreciated your
steering that through into statute
the biggest decision that a college
student is making I'm sorry that a high
school student is making is whether
they're going to invest in their
post-secondary education that's their
biggest financial decision they are
going to make
this is going to be part of that
implementation and
of our education goals for all of our
students in the state and it is entirely
consistent with that effort
thank you further questions
representative and then representative
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Senator Khan for uh for
joining us this morning
um
I I
among other things I'm I chair The
Advisory board over at nhti so I've got
a lot of familiarity with New
Hampshire's community colleges and and I
think um uh a lot of
um families
um people families across the state
um recognize and they they certainly
hear this in the media read this you
know
um on online reports and and everywhere
else that New Hampshire's Community
College tuition is among the highest in
the country and I guess I'm wondering
how would a family find out if um if if
under that you know with that is the
backdrop that New Hampshire's community
colleges have some of the highest
tuition in the country how would they
know if um if they qualified to attend
uh Community College at virtually no
cost
they have to complete a
federal financial aid application which
is the FAFSA form okay thanks thanks for
thank you representative
thank you thank you for answering my
question
um you had said
to the answer to Rhett McDonald's
question 80 is that 80 of the students
are now staying in their state
which was her question
or is that 80 are filling out the FAFSA
if that was your question representative
McDonald I sorry I did not that's not
what I answered I answered a question of
uh what was the FAFSA completion rate in
Louisiana
uh I don't know what percent is staying
in the state
uh
I I I don't know that sorry what I do
know is that Louisiana's rate was around
50 percent
prior to the implementation of their
statute and uh and and they they just
they they
did a great job of implementing this and
uh and then they're at 80 percent New
Hampshire is in the lower half of our 50
states at 50 thank you
represent uh dry you hit your hand up
first thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh when we raise
the compulsory age of Education to 18 we
all of a sudden had a great graduation
rate from our schools so I think
requiring the FAFSA is going to
artificially inflate our numbers of at
FAFSA completions and I'm like
representative McDonald trying to
correlate filling out a form and your
end game which you presented today which
was an educated Workforce that's filling
lots of shifts and I'm having trouble
getting from this point to this point
can you help me yeah
um I I encourage you to go to the
federal student aid website uh it says
very clearly there's a paragraph that
says FAFSA completion has a high
correlation rate to college attendance
uh
I agreed it might boost the numbers uh
but it made you know the I just focus on
the goal the goal here is
how do we show that a post-secondary
education is Affordable and the only way
to prove that to a family is to go
through the completion process
it's no guarantee of attendance did you
add your hand up represent cordelli
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you uh
for being here again
um yeah I guess I'm I was a little
confused about the the whole race
concept
um between New England states and other
states
um because a part of my problem I think
is
um and uh representative try mentioned a
correlation
um it seems like
you're presenting that there's a
correlation between companies relocating
to New Hampshire and FAFSA completion
rates and I I don't see where we can
find a correlation like that
well I think
I think that isn't too hard a leap but
I'll try to connect those dots as I see
them uh
showing that a college or a
post-secondary again there are lots of
ways to complete a post-secondary
education without getting a community
college or bachelor's degree uh
seeing that that is an affordable option
uh promotes education
and and enrollment it breaks down one of
the most insignificant the most
significant factor uh deterrent barrier
to a post-secondary experience is cost
we have we have made
education Beyond High School very costly
in our country we
uh and
there are industries that are you know
what Texas implemented it without a
statute
they did it through their Department of
Education
uh
where is Oracle relocated where has uh
uh Tesla relocated it's in Texas their
completion rate is one of the top three
in the country
uh I'm just trying to connect the dots
the they have you know they're they're
educating people in the fields that
these companies need to hire and and
that's where they're going
uh Massachusetts has done
extraordinarily well in biotech
and it's because
they're they've got a high College goal
rate you can just see it
and and by the way I wanted to have a
map for you it's on the website it's in
color and you guys know better than I
apparently there is not a color printer
anywhere in
the legislative branches
so I can't get it to you but but again
you got to look at Massachusetts and see
the GIS mapping and and see the the
greens and blues where there's 60 to 80
percent completion rates and then
compare it to New Hampshire where in
Rochester it's 20 sorry representative
grassy uh they're a bunch of schools in
my district Gene I know I think the
superintendent signed the letter
apparently but uh the completion rate is
50 percent
it's 45 I mean we got to do better
follow up thank you I just point out
that um since you mentioned Texas a few
years ago I had the opportunity to talk
with Governor Abbott and he talked about
five reasons five ways that
our state could become like Texas
um he didn't mention FAFSA percentage
number two though was right to work so I
think I I would rather go with right to
work than FAFSA completion rates
another question or is that just a
comment okay thank you very much
representative Damon then represent
Belcher
thank you thank you for taking my
question
so I understand the value of the FAFSA
and could speak to personal experience
with students who
needed help to understand that they
could afford to go to higher education
what I don't understand
is
or have not been able to come up with in
my head some way that this would be
harmful to students or districts
can you speak to that is there any
negative side
I think
what I summarize from the letter that
you're going to read
is that this is another requirement
when districts probably feel that if
they do the right thing by their
students they will produce the right
outcome
without the need for a statute
uh
we're not there and if and if we can
demonstrate that we can get there and in
two three years from now after this is
implemented we see that the rate went up
to 70 percent the systems are in place
and this uh then then we win
and and you can repeal the bill uh the
statute because it it it it could be
implemented without but we don't have
the the Department of Education uh
Staffing that they do in Most states and
so you're not going to see the kind of
impetus and follow-through uh in New
Hampshire uh and I I it just with the
statute in the last two years to kind of
follow through that's happened with
neath the New Hampshire higher education
financial assistance entity they have
amped up their work they're going to
produce video segments frequently Asked
videos specific to New Hampshire
families and New Hampshire schools
and uh I mean
the rollout is underway this hasn't been
an act that has been dormant for two
years people have been working on this
and and in collaboration with counselors
in the state so
anyway I I think
I I I think the the idea of mandates uh
in public education are something that
uh
folks would just assume Nazi and statute
and just follow through and good intent
but if that was the case we wouldn't
have education goals would we Mr
chairman
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um getting a little bit to the heart of
the matter here I think beyond the FAFSA
there's an underlying assumption for the
FAFSA the universal that the universal
attendance of of college is is good and
wise for all people
um however we're seeing that not only
are a lot of people having difficulty
repaying their college debt there are
also a lot of people are having a hard
time finding jobs in the fields that
their degrees would lend towards so I I
think that the bit of a two-parter if
you wouldn't mind is is it a good idea
for Universal College attendance among
students and uh does the state does the
government have any moral culpability
for students who are now having a hard
time paying these debts off when we're
essentially coercing them toward College
um so I think the goal of post-secondary
Education ought to be an industry
recognized credentials
bachelor's degree is a great industry
recognized credential it did you seldom
have to explain much more Beyond uh for
many jobs right uh says bachelor's
degree required right
um
but that's not the only way to get a
industry recognized credential there are
many ways you might even do it through
your high school education right uh
so no I'm not saying that every student
is going to go I'm saying that I think
it is well recognized that cost is a
barrier to post-secondary uh education
and achieving industry recognized
credentials and that this is a a
mechanism for
minimizing that cost in the same way
that it's minimizing debt we know that
there are college students
niece knows and they have sent and
presented to me
that there were seven million dollars
left on the table
of New Hampshire high school graduates
last year who went to college or went to
a post-secondary experience and did not
complete a FAFSA and they were eligible
they'd know that because uh their
colleges that they applied for Aid at
their colleges or wherever they attended
anyway we know that there's money being
left on the table because people don't
fill it out and then go
and we know that people don't go because
cost is a barrier
follow up if I made this very briefly I
think we're in agreement that it's not
universally wise for every single
student to go to college but if that's
the case and some of these students know
that and their parents know that and
it's a different course why would we
then compel them to fill this out
um so again there are in the statute I
hope I hope everyone's taking a look at
it there are three mechanisms for
satisfying this requirement one is fill
it out another is say I've been
presented with the information I
understand it but I'm not filling it out
and sign it and sign that
and that's fine
you've you satisfied the requirement and
the third way is that you didn't do one
of the two and the principal knows that
uh all you've been in the class you've
had the information presented to you uh
sorry you didn't fill it out but I'm
checking you off anyway
and that form has been completed by the
Department of Education so that it's one
form every school district in the state
uses the same form and uh
and it it's just held by in the students
file it's that's it
reps in the hall did you have your hand
up
okay represent Murray
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I was just wondering
how this applies to homeschool students
because we have a fairly large
homeschool population in New Hampshire
it doesn't
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
there seems to have been some confusion
so I'd like to Repose my question I
still am struggling to see the
correlation between FAFSA completion
versus in-state College tuition could
you point me in the committee to some
statistic that says a student graduating
from a New Hampshire High School having
completed the FAFSA form is more likely
to attend a New Hampshire College than a
student who did not complete the form
yeah I I don't think I can do that
except to say that anif does most of the
uh
High School College nights
and presents
as an authoritative body they they run
workshops for counselors in the high
schools uh anyway they they're really an
acknowledged source for uh the
transition between high school and
post-secondary experiences
and I'm sorry and they uh
as they present
they're going to use New Hampshire
schools as the example
here's what the costs are if you don't
fill out the FAFSA here's the sticker
price if you fill out the FAFSA and you
qualify for assistance here's how much
that price goes down
if you
do that step
here's how much institutional Aid you
can expect to receive
and so those examples are presented
directly to the student
now in the FAFSA form you may recall I
recall you fill in at least I mean you
can fill in one school
and satisfy the requirement
uh
but
you can fill in five schools
and hopefully they're filling in New
Hampshire colleges for this maybe
they're the safety school but it does re
then offer them what is that comparative
cost I mean the price we always get
mixed up in higher education what's the
cost and what's the price the cost is a
sticker cost
the price is a discounted rate and you
go on the federal uh scorecard right
College scorecard site and and you can
find
here's this here's the sticker price but
students on average at that college only
pay this
uh and that's because they filled out a
FAFSA and they've got an Institutional
Aid and that's how much you you know is
the price
the mechanisms in our state can
improve
the percentage of
high school graduates
staying in state to attend school
but
even our in-state costs are high yes
yes and uh and we've got to make efforts
to to demonstrate
that access is still a possibility
without incurring huge amounts of debt
if I may follow up please yep
so I understand from what you are saying
and evidence from neef that there may be
reason to believe a correlation exists
between FAFSA completion and their
likelihood of a student to pick an
in-state college but from what I
understand is it true that there is not
evidence of this time to suggest that we
can guarantee a correlation exists
between FAFSA completion and in-state
tuition
foreign
there's just a correlation between facet
completion and college or post-secondary
attendance okay that correlation is
established and the federal government
has it on their website but in state New
Hampshire versus out of state that's a
speculative correlation at least at this
moment in time I can't make that
correlation only that we are we have the
highest percent of our students
that go on to college
attending out of state of any state in
the country
uh
we know that too thank you
I have a question there's a little
follow-up as a trustee with the
university system New Hampshire we
struggle all the time why they are doing
that one of which is of course we know
our tuitions if we're not top it's right
below UVM then uh but I have two two
issues here and two questions or one
question there appears to be an
assumption several assumptions within
this this process we have in place one
that
this whole process is not taking place
right now that our local school boards
and superintendents and principals are
not
establishing a process in which to
encourage students to look at this
whether it be the granite guarantee loan
or whether it be FAFSA
through our counseling processes there's
an assumption that may not be working or
is not working the way you should the
other assumption I see is that that it
parallels a little bit of the first one
with our local control
that that the state has a better way of
telling these students this is what
you're going to have to do
uh and some students may say I've passed
the ask lab I'm going off in the
military or they may say hey I've got
that industry recognized credential
already through the Career Technical
education center so why am I filling
this I have no desire I'm going to go
off become an electricians because why
while you read it in the Wall Street
Journal every day just about recently
there's a decline in students going to
college and why while the skill that
they're attaining in the school whether
even being high school and CTE is going
to net them a better income than coming
out with a degree in political science
or history
so I I think there's some assumptions
here that I I just have never been able
to get my hand on why we feel we can do
better than local control which I feel
is already doing this
can you help me out with that a little
bit
um
so you it's being done and it we can't
say that through this mechanism the
state is putting a high value on
trying to inform
students and families of the
opportunities that exist for them
that's what we're saying as a state uh
with with that statute
um I I agree but
schools the the counselor
the student to counselor ratio we know
uh in in schools varies dramatically
some schools are able to spend more time
with their students
in planning their
education to Career guidance than other
districts
and
apparently
it's you can see what those I bet there
there's another high correlation
if you've got a high student a counselor
ratio in your school district chances
are you're not spending as much time on
Career preparation with your students
um
so I you know I I
that that's the uh I mean the evidence
is there
there are so many districts that are 50
and less and less in our state I mean
how do you get to an average of 50 you
got a bunch of schools a few schools
that are over and a whole bunch of them
there are less
uh and that's just not representative of
of
of of
where the jobs are going to go in the
future
and as a past principal and
administrator
the top goal was always the student
and ensuring that the student is going
off to a Workforce career pathway that's
where the student is really thought
about and been given support by our
staff and parents my concern is there's
22 superintendents here now who are
saying that this process is probably
already happening in my school why do I
need the state now to mandate this under
the the threat of withholding graduation
door number one is completed door number
two is is uh just I had the instruction
I it's part of my financial literacy
requirement and I signed off that I've
had it and I and I'm not filling it out
that's door number two and door number
three is the safety net the principal
can say
we've made everything the students had
that opportunity to complete it uh and
and chose not to door number three
it's not a heavy stiff requirement
because we've got a lot more
requirements in statute that are a lot
stiffer than this
thank you are there further questions
represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and so so
Jay I I I I recall
attending uh ncsl higher education
um uh work group
um meeting with you several years ago
four or five years ago and this it was
the first time that that this had really
um uh hit my radar screen and uh and I
remember you speaking quite passionately
about it at that um at that meeting in
fact we were sitting at I think a table
during lunch with um with uh some
senators from uh from Louisiana who were
telling us how successful this um this
program uh has been in their state and
and the the line of question the most
recent line of questioning here sort of
reminded me of not just that um uh that
meeting at ncsl but also meetings that
we've had here and people that have
joined us in committee for for similar
related bills and how much of this
effort is not actually being
generated locally but generated through
Partnerships with
um with neef as you've mentioned but
also with you know Trio programs like
education Talent search Upward Bound I
was writing a few of them down
apprenticeship New Hampshire the New
Hampshire charitable foundation and I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about how the current statute which
comes into effect on July 1st leverages
those
um you know third-party uh initiatives
in supporting our Public Schools thanks
for that question uh neef New Hampshire
higher education financial assistance
Corporation has assembled
representatives of those groups as you
just identified and they have come to
the table to to help
talk about what's the kind of training
for uh the professional development
opportunities for counselors uh that
need that's needed what kind of uh
frequently asked questions are there uh
you mentioned it New Hampshire
charitable Foundation has come up with
its strategy for uh paying for one
course to college
so that it again is providing more
financial incentive for people to attend
uh yeah the the trio programs and and
Upward Bound uh programs that are
college-based federally funded uh are
instrumental in this and so are the
states colleges the 22 College financial
aid officers a part of the overall
planning and they too participate in the
school workshops that take place so yes
it has amped up the collaborations
between all of those parties thank you
now let's just remind the committee and
I'll take the questions from several
more people but uh we've spent an hour
on the first primarily with uh Senator
Khan here
we have several other folks are here to
speak on this bill right now several
superintendents
um and then we have two others which are
coming up afterwards so I know we're
getting what this pretty much taken care
of in the first
non-germaine men here but uh let's let's
limit the number of questions we have
left I know representative electus you
have a question and representative D
Simone has one
pardon me
for another person okay yes the
superintendents will be up next and if
you don't mind uh uh super net Fournier
and belkey you could come up together if
you want to we have two chairs right
here
um okay let's representative
so I just want to make sure I'm
understanding the FAFSA
so if I'm a family and my goal is to
find out
would would I even qualify
I have to name a college and that
college will be getting my personal
information
even if I don't qualify
is that correct
yes I believe so okay thank you yep
are there any other questions for
Senator Khan
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman
okay I'd like to call forward Brian
dokey and Mike Fournier
thank you
see I think you're both on this letter
here and you're probably both come come
from the similar angles uh so and we
rode together
makes sense we're happy to do this
together okay so once you introduce
yourselves and
we'll get on with it sure
um I'm Brian Mulkey I'm the
superintendent of schools in Goffstown
in New Boston uh Mike Fournier
superintendent schools for the Bedford
school district
so I think um I'll I'll start and then
I'll hand it off to Mr Fournier I just
um I agree with everything that Senator
Khan said I I think that he makes a lot
of compelling points
um I support families filling out the
FAFSA I have two College age kids both
of my kids go to the University of New
Hampshire I'm paying
um the highest uh in-state tuition in
the entire country I believe
so I am a supporter of kids going on to
school I'm a supporter of kids having
multiple options my issue with this is
don't put schools in a position where
we're going to refuse giving someone a
high school diploma because of a
decision that their parents made that's
my whole singular argument I support
fastest being done I support an educated
Workforce I support people considering
all of the options including higher ed
just don't put high school principals
and superintendents in a position where
I'm going to withhold someone's diploma
because they didn't fill out a form or
I'm going to fill out forms and say well
I'm going to fill one out a waiver for
everybody and it's going to water down
the the effect of what you're hoping to
have um occur
uh great thank you uh again Mike
Fournier superintendent of Bedford thank
you for uh having me here I've actually
never spoke to a body in the legislature
before so this is a first for me uh we
have a lot to do in our day jobs we
don't often get out
um so essentially uh Brian and I have
not talked about this in depth but I
agree with what he said in my linchpin
uh on this issue is is really singular
as well uh is that we are tying a
parental duty to a student's graduation
and in Bedford at least when a student
graduates from high school it is based
on what they know and are able to do it
is not based on what they know and what
their parents can do and so when you
graduate from Bedford High School you
not your parents can do Algebra you can
write you can read it is not what your
parents can do and so this ties a
student's graduation to what their
parents elect to do or not to do so
that's sort of the first piece the
second is and you all know this we're
sort of in this environment where
there's a fair amount of tension between
families and schools already and as
Brian can attest there are a number of
requirements that school districts have
that we that we do and we're happy to do
them this is one that in my opinion and
in the opinion of my five board members
is an overreach and an overstep while I
do conceptually agree with most of what
Senator Khan shared
I certainly do not make the connection
between a Better Business environment
and filling out FAFSA
nor am I going to compare New
Hampshire's high quality education to
that of Mississippi or Louisiana
um and I'm not sure an arbitrary 80
percent uh I don't know what it's going
to get us however I will say for both of
our communities we spend a significant
amount of time through Naviance in
Bedford through meetings with nice
through parent meetings working with
families to make sure they understand
the options that are available to them
so that they understand what is before
them so when they go out off to college
so I have three I have three kids of my
own two of which have graduated from
college and one who is currently
attending proudly UNH
um
and so you know I can
arbit not arbitrarily I can say I think
with some um certainty that one of the
reasons why many New Hampshire students
don't go to school in New Hampshire is
because it's too expensive
um I will say out of the 15 colleges
that all of the 15 colleges my three
kids applied to every single one of
those colleges required FAFSA in order
for them to receive scholarships so the
school district didn't require it but
the college did and so as they were
attending college in order to apply for
scholarships they had to fill out the
Federal Form and so from our point of
view this is not an administrative
burden that we're looking to avoid it's
really linking a parent's job to that of
a student and adding an additional layer
of possible tension and conflict between
parents and schools that really don't
belong there it's a family decision not
a school decision
further questions representative Tanner
thank you um I taught high school for a
long time
had an opportunity to talk to a lot of
kids particularly in their Junior and
Senior year about where they're going I
I still uh when I go to the store and
there's a kid bagging I say you know
what's your plans right that's a
teacher's job I noticed in the letter as
I'm just kind of zipping down it here
there's one statement that's made it it
says that the mandate's unnecessary
because families are already aware of
the benefits of completing the FAFSA and
many do so voluntarily
that wasn't my experience that there
were students I felt had the ability and
had the interest to go to college but we
were told constantly by their family
that they just didn't have the money and
that it would be a tremendous burden on
them and that they should go and bag
groceries at Hannaford's for a while and
maybe get enough money to go to
to take a class at the local Community
College
um and they were afraid of FAFSA because
a lot of the information that's out
there and when you talk about the
tension
was that it was a government overreach
and that it was the government going to
find out about their income and blah
blah blah blah
um but I'd just like to to say how are
you sure or how and both of you are
coming from great school districts uh
and we know some of the school districts
are really struggling in New Hampshire I
represent Sunapee so you know it and I
taught at cures Arch so those are two
big districts that really push guidance
counseling and mentoring kids in their
Junior and Senior year what they're
going to do afterwards but how how can
we be sure that all families are aware
of the benefits of completing the FAFSA
the ones that aren't already voluntarily
doing it and pushing their kids towards
you know making sure they have some
direction after school
that's a great question thank you for
asking it um I don't know if I'm allowed
to speak how freely I can speak there's
three amendments I believe uh one of
them I think is so so the other piece I
think this body it's important for you
to hear is the superintendents
Association when we spoke to them there
was not there's not an outcry to Simply
remove it like this is a terrible thing
that has happened every superintendent
on this letter believes in filling out
that form and providing opportunity to
students the issue that they have is
making it a requirement for graduation
But to answer your question more
directly is I believe one of the
Amendments sort of um
outlines what many school districts do
of which Goffstown and Bedford are one
which is provide parent Knights provide
parents and students with all the
information necessary meet with guidance
counselors bring in neef so that when
students are working our students as
freshmen meet with their advisors and
their counselors and start talking about
the college process and have these
conversations early and often so that by
the time they get to their Junior and
Senior year they're in full swing and
ready to go and so the amendment that
was brought forth I Believe by you
representative Ladd I think would be
very appropriate because it actually
makes a requirement for school districts
to do those things which I think are
needed and appropriate but it stops
short of of putting in a requirement
it is my sense I don't know if you agree
or disagree Brian yeah can you call sure
so um at one point I taught a
Cooperative class that was that was
um you know underwritten by the federal
government as a pilot program and it was
targeted at students who were
um
BC students but had a lot of potential
that that teachers realized had a lot of
potential and for the most part that
their parents had not gone to college or
had even not graduated from high school
we took a trip
first of all those parents don't show up
to the FAFSA uh requirement or FAFSA you
know the college nights and and all that
stuff we went down to
um a college
um and I'm trying to think of the name
of it it was down in I believe Nashua
and it was it was actually a college
that was set up like Notre Dame or
something like that that was set up in a
former department store okay and the
reason we were there was one of the
students very interested in going into
physical therapy and I knew one of the
people that was uh adjunct or a
professor down there and it was you know
it was it was great I mean it just it
didn't look like Dartmouth obviously but
it you know it was a college and and uh
working all at the time and um
when we got back this this young gal who
was really wanted to do that
um both her parents uh were first
generation uh people
um she they neither one of them had
graduated from high school they they
were afraid of people that talked about
college they were afraid of FAFSA
um basically and and she was in a very
big quandary how how to go about doing
all this and it took a lot of help from
you know like I said our school was very
supportive and but I'm wondering if that
same child was a student a senior over
in another school that's close to us
that's struggling
um whether she would be where she is now
and she's a physical therapist
so
I'm just I'm just wondering how you I
think the purpose of this was not
that you didn't have enough information
for kids whose parents want them to go
to college or kids who really kind of
think about college and come from a
supportive family in in that particular
line but it was to catch those kids and
those families that
um need a little a little bit extra uh
and not incentive but totally but need
um
need some way to see that that there's a
pathway through to maybe the dreams that
the kid really wants to do and money
shouldn't be the the object and
particularly with you know we have
um colleges there there is ringing up
like us and you you know that are very
you know fairly more affordable and
certainly the community college system
is making a lot a lot of it more
affordable with the you know the
different courses they can take in high
school and get credit for it so I'm just
wondering do you think you're reaching
those people and because you've said in
the letter that you know it's it's a
done deal it's unnecessary because we've
reached all those do you not see that
this would maybe open the pathway for
more students
um so I I can't answer that definitively
what I can say is this makes it feel
more like a stick and less like a carrot
and so you know to the extent that you
can get people to fill up FAFSA as a
stick then maybe
um but I think the real I think the the
intent that we'd like to get after is
exactly what you say because those are
the kids that really pull on our
heartstrings that we want to make sure
that any student that has a desire to
pursue higher education has all the
options available to them and so to your
point there are some schools that have
more resources to do that than others
um but whether you're a school district
like Bedford that has resources or a
school district that doesn't have
resources at the end of the day this is
going to be a checklist
and it and it's not you know one of the
questions was asked earlier regarding
well what happens if a parent doesn't
and
superintendents will be very
um
they will not be holding kids from
graduation because of this and I don't
know how effective it's going to be
getting after those kids I'd like to see
something that would come forth that's
more of a carrot and I see
representative Ladd's Amendment as more
of a carrot for those kinds of students
but I do appreciate the question
represent uh Myler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here and thank
you for the work you do
we uh we often see your representatives
from the association here
but we rarely have an opportunity to
talk with people who are actually in the
field on a daily basis working with kids
and teachers and thank you for the work
you're doing my question revolves around
the waiver issue
we've heard that there are two different
types of waivers one for the parent one
from the uh from a principal could you
address that as a part of the
conversation here thank you
um so I think that's par I think that's
somewhat nebulous right now
um
I have not yet seen the waiver or if the
state is has established a waiver of the
doe they may have I just haven't seen it
yet uh of course the school would have
to do it right now we're having
conversations about what would that look
like essentially it's going to be a
checklist for us those students who have
filled it out assigned parents think of
a permission slip right you know that
says I I either I've completed it yes
I'm not going to complete it no and then
of course this is actually the timing of
this is perfect because this is the time
where I meet with my high school
principal and he says okay I'll say to
him how many students are on the list
that are that may not graduate on June
10th in Bedford and so last week I think
we had eight and so we go over every
single student what is it that's missing
that this child has missing where they
can't graduate and so this will will add
that we'll add this to that list
assuming the law is in place next June
we will do that but what that exactly
looks like I think we're going to have
to tease that out
cardelli
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you both
for being here
um how will you know if family has
completed the FAFSA
okay uh
I believe from bedford's point of view
unless we're directed otherwise by the
department of Ed it will simply be a
signature from a parent that they've
done so
but we will require no other proof than
that
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you please
explain to me uh what the process is for
a student who's going to go into the
trades as opposed to going on to college
and refusing the parents refusing the
FAFSA can you explain to me what your
process is to help that student graduate
on time
right so one of the things that we have
done and I think the department of Ed
has done with the legislator to
legislative body too is to provide a
number of Pathways to students
understanding not not that not every
Pathway to graduation is the same for
every child
so for example I believe the state has
20 credits that are required for
graduation
Bedford has 24 but we also have a 20
credit requirement there are some
students that take High set because the
traditional route is not right for them
that's formerly GED there are students
that have multiple Pathways there are
some students who will come to us early
with their families and say we're not
going to be a traditional student for
you and we want to move through a
pathway differently than a typical
student would and so our what our
counselors do is they meet with those
students and they talk about what are
the options available to you and what
are the pros and cons of those options
right so some students will graduate
from high school with a 24 credit degree
and go on and help run the family
business some will go into a military
academy some will go to a four year some
will go to a two-year some will take a
gap year
um but but as Senator Connor mentioned
I'm a vast majority of Bedford students
go on to college
but so in our case the students that
you're talking about who go into trade
schools it's a much smaller group at
least for us I don't know if your
process yeah and I would say in general
we're encouraging those kids to go on to
trade school you're you're going to make
as much money as an HVAC technician as
you're going to be if you go get an
accounting degree in a lot of places
right now my brother's a union plumber
in Boston he's doing just fine
so we we really encourage kids that are
interested in the trades
um we want kids to have a lot of
Pathways we want them to be able to
follow what their dreams are what
they're interested in and we want to do
that for everybody what we don't want to
do is say you didn't fill out the form
unfortunately you're not getting your
diploma today I'm not going to do that
I've been a superintendent for 10 years
I'm not going to withhold a diploma
because a parent didn't do this
picking this question how will when this
goes into effect change your process
for those kids who are going into the
trades and making bucket loads of money
I think we would just have to have that
kind of sheet kind of like Mr Fournier
was saying that I either completed the
form or I understand that it's available
and I'm choosing not to do it so we
would have some kind of a form like that
but again now now you're chasing
hundreds of graduates did you get your
form in did you do your it's just more
of a burden on our local public schools
just give the schools one more thing
they'll take care of it they always do
that's what this feels like it comes
with an apology
you know I'm sorry Mrs Des Moines this
is a requirement we have to we have to
do it you kindly please return this to
the school district well why do I have
to do it and then we have to explain it
and then there's a process and it's it
is fine if that is what you want for
your child and you understand it but
there's
if you've ever sent a permission slip
home to 23 students and expected to get
them all back for something they want to
do
imagine sending something home for
something they don't want to do right
thank you
any further questions representative
Hall
the chair thank you for taking my
question
so door number three doesn't that get
you off the hook or what you do in
Bedford and Goffstown like you're giving
these parent nights and whatnot so door
three is saying you know we gave you the
information doesn't that get you off the
hook for every kid
I think that it does but then it goes to
the question what's the point of the law
to begin with I think it's the other
schools that maybe don't do what you're
doing which is which is why I think
representative Ladd's amendment is so
appropriate because it puts the
requirement where it ought to be which
is
for for instance school districts so
Bedford has had a a personal finance
course for the entirety the school
district's been open for 14 years my
understanding is now all school
districts are required to do that so I
think having a requirement to make sure
that students are aware and informed of
this is very very appropriate
putting a parent's responsibility and
tying that to a kid's graduation
it isn't right
graduation is what a child knows and is
able to do
and it should be a celebration
any further questions
last last question representative
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much uh superintendent swornier
bulky for uh being with us um this
morning I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
well actually let me sort of preface it
with with um when um when when my kids
were going through uh through school
um K-12
uh they they did very well and they did
very well after graduation and and after
after college as well but um but I don't
think it was without a lot of work on
the part of my wife and I and our family
to make sure that they got up on time in
the morning made the school bus had
breakfast
um got to school on time all of that
stuff and um you know without a little
bit of that encouragement uh I think
Luke might have slept in until 11
o'clock in the morning every morning and
and um and I'm not sure but I suspect
that would have affected his performance
and and and success in high school in
particular but I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about you know
those sorts of things that that how
Student Success is related to what
parents do whether that's feeding them
or putting money in their pocket so that
they can buy a school lunch or fill out
the free and reduced price launch
paperwork so that they're fueled up and
ready to learn
that day and and maybe how that reflects
on on Bedford and Goffstown which you
know are are as has been said are are
tremendous very strong districts in the
state
um and but how it reflects on your
family's um you know their rate of of
post-secondary degree attainment and and
how that
you know looks I mean is that pretty
much standard across the state or do we
see different things across state
because these are Statewide policies
that we're talking about I I would say
certainly the challenges in Bedford and
Goffstown look different than challenges
in other communities in the state for
sure but I would agree that
um
achievements that our kids have are
reflective of their parents for sure so
you're reluctant wake up student in the
morning uh you getting him to school on
time was very important for his success
in school
okay thank you
um so if may I make a comment I agree
with you my college kid still sleeps
until 10 or 11 sometimes
um so this is just something interesting
to share so Bedford we do have our share
of problems that this year we just
instituted for the first time at one of
our elementary schools a breakfast
program it started off about a month ago
and we started with 25 students and then
it grew to 50 students and then I think
the last number I heard was 75 students
reading breakfast and the principal
reported
um to us he said Mike the behavior of
the students has improved so much since
this program started and it's sort of a
basic thing that kids learn when they
have a full tummy right
I'm sure other parents are feeding them
at home or most of them are certainly
and so I think as parents we do have a
responsibility and I and for me I think
that sort of gets to the heart of the
matter that it is a parental
responsibility I do think as a school
district we have a responsibility to
sort of open the door show them the
options make sure the buffet is
available so that we can explain all the
options available to students and make
sure the pathways are there I you know
as I have said consistently I just think
I'd like to
stop short of making it a requirement
for graduation
thank you very much I appreciate it
thank you thank you is there anybody
else to wants to testify on
this amendment
not seeing any will close this hearing
and we'll go into the next hearing which
is also on the same 130 SB 136
non-germaine of which I am the response
that so I will hand the gavel off to uh
representative cordelli and I'll be out
front
thank you
thank you so this is uh Amendment
2023-1744h
um and uh we'll call on representative
lad for its introduction
thank you very much uh so I'd like to
introduce 1744.
um there's a number of reasons why I've
done this my past experience as the
school principal and administrator
um hone in a lot of what's discussed
within this amendment but I'm also
reflecting just as a father and as a
grandfather I've sent my own children
off to Texas A M to Elmira College the
University of Idaho uh just recently
grandkids to St Lawrence University and
University of Maine why University of
Maine it was cheaper than unh
and so that's one of the reasons why
people are leaving this state but I'd
like to talk specifically to the
rationale behind this bill and I think
we've talked about that the intent is
yes I recognize the value of FAFSA
when we first heard this bill presented
several years back
and it goes in effect this this coming
July we had that bill introduced to us
where there was a mandate there was a
mandate you don't do this you don't
graduate we amended that in committee
here to allow for the provision that if
they signed off in this form they were
able to you know they would graduate if
they didn't want a complete FAFSA that
was a result of House Education
now if you look at the amendment in
lines 12 through 22 it explains the
process it says
it's every district has to be
responsibility to ensure that students
are provided the the FAFSA
it also gets into the middle of that the
discretion of the school board and the
school to decide what they do in
communicating with a student about their
next step as they leave High School
whether it's going to be community
college system
post-secondary education at the
University level or college level or
going into the trades that is that at
the discretion of the local school to
decide how they're going to go about
doing that whether and there's then also
the processes and the bottom that where
we give some suggestions of how that may
occur I'm just going to reflect for a
moment of what's going on at Woodsville
High School Woodsville High School is a
school that does not have the resources
they're not like a Bedford or Goffstown
they're a smaller High School roughly
around 250 kids they're in a district
which is a property poor town that's
Haverhill
and we have an outstanding program
within that school allowing children
students to become familiar with FAFSA
and with their opportunities which are
Beyond 12th grade
each year one of the teachers happens to
be the social studies teacher takes
students on a field trip to Boston
where do they go they go to Northeastern
they go to BU they go to Wentworth they
go to BC they go all those schools down
there which students might be interested
in and they challenge the students to
look at these schools they also through
their personal finance literacy and
economics provide this understanding of
the FAFSA and the need to complete it
because there are monies available I
just went through it as a grandfather
with my grandson uh the one that went to
University of Maine fortunately went on
a full ride scholarship if you want that
you got to get in athletics however the
grandson he's also in athletics but
happens to be a division three school so
they have to do it by way of a a little
bit off there seventy thousand dollar a
year tuition
and so the rest of it comes up from
FAFSA and things such as that and we
went through and explained that he went
to St Johnsbury Academy much like
Pinkerton Academy right here in New
Hampshire at St J we have kids coming in
from uh Littleton from Bath from
Piermont from a number of communities up
and down that River including lime
and at that school they have a parent
evening
grandparent evening whatever you adult
wants to come in and be informed about
FAFSA they also through their teachers
they have advisors to these students and
they're constantly talking my my uh
sophomore right now uh next year has
already been advised and we are taking a
trip this summer down to UNC uh in
Wilmington has a wonderful science
program in terms of engineering related
to Seacoast
and it's also one of your Best Buys in
terms of expenses and that's been
conveyed To Us by the school
and so you know I think it's important
to recognize that all these schools
whether they're a resource strong or
resource weak School in terms of funding
and the resources they make this
available and they do the counseling and
that's what it's all about the
counseling the working with the teachers
and parents interacting and asking these
questions and students ask the same
things so
um and also for Career Technical
education
we have more students are going on to
Career Technical education out of that
program than we do even out of our high
schools
and so when I talked to a student when
we were down in Salem where are you
going to school in the CTE program she
said oh I was already accepted last year
Virginia Tech
that's also being done through our CTE
programs there is no need to have a
mandate that you're not going to
graduate or the threat if you don't get
this formula if you don't sign off and
for a principal as I as a principal
would have to chase students around that
is what quite a chore I have better
things to do in terms of curriculum
instruction and working directly with
the the management of the school then
trying to chase down ensure that you
complete the FAFSA that's not my job as
an administrator it's really that of the
counselor and the teachers working
collaboratively with the parent
and so I believe that we need to have a
process in place in statute that's what
this bill does it ensures the process is
there it takes out this penalty of in
this threat of you won't graduate we
have a lot of indicators like 13 or 14
is what is an opportunity for an
adequate education in RSA 193.
and those indicators are indicators that
reflect on what they did either in ctes
or where they're going off the ASVAB if
they participated in
um uh Advanced courses in school all
that's there uh I don't think it's
necessary to put another mandate like
this in I do think it's necessary that
schools ensure that students are
provided this opportunity in this
information and that's what this bill
does it does it without the Mandate so I
won't talk anymore about it uh seeing
that we have had quite a discussion
already I'll take any questions if they
have questions if you have questions
thank you
questions
representative Murray
thank you
um I was wondering if this one also does
not apply to homeschool students no this
is not
homeschoolers students are over here in
a separate leg of the stool uh this does
not apply to them would there be a way
to make it apply to them
I I don't think it's necessary to you
know when we've had bills come for us
and we're in the hall and we usually get
a huge turnout when it's a homeschool
bill or a charter school bill
you listen to homeschool parents and
they're very engaged yes there's a few
outliers as there are in regular public
education the majority of them are there
doing this right now with their students
uh so I I think they're quite capable I
think what we have to do is concern
ourselves with you know our public
academies our public charter schools our
public high schools and leave it at that
um you know we we put a lot of mandates
out the superintendents lately
and Dr Appleby's behind me and we put a
request out to know how many teachers
they were short during the school year
yeah but we initially got what 20
percent up to 40 percent maybe about 56
percent compliance compliance when we
wanted to have the uh
school-based management plans for
emergency situations handed in to us
when we first talked about that on the
public school infrastructure commission
we had 20 percent return 20 return when
we put a
the carrot out there you won't receive
any of this grant money any of this 30
plus million dollars within two weeks we
had them all in
so you know we we put a lot of mandates
out there
um I can't believe there's a person in
the business being a superintendent a
principal or a commissioner or Deputy
Commissioner of Education really doesn't
love kids and really is there for the
purpose of ensuring that we can get
every child along that path so I think
this is basically something that we
should be doing as far as communicating
FAFSA but it should not be a mandate
um that's just I don't know how we're
ever going to turn around to a student
and saying in another year from now from
this summer saying you didn't complete
this form you're not going to graduate
that's a lawyer's dream
especially when they have all their
units for graduation completed and
satisfied you're going to turn around
and say you don't graduate and where am
I going well I'm going off to become a
plumber and earn more money than I would
have as a political science or history
major at college
thank you
representative luno
um sure thank you very much Mr chair
um and thanks for bringing this forward
and I think there's there's
um there's some you know it certainly as
you played a strong rationale through
this but I was wondering if such a
brought up the Woodsville example if you
could let the committee know what that
completion rate is I can't tell you what
the FAFSA completion rate is I can't
tell you what it is for the state you'd
probably find it off in the federal
government
when we're looking at this there there
are other ways you know we are a poor
town and if you're going to go off the
Plymouth or Keene or unh
Granite guarantee pays for that entire
tuition
so I don't need FAFSA I probably could
come out with you know no debt so I
don't know if if FAFSA is the the answer
to all this uh I think what the the the
thing we should be looking at how many
students go off from Woodsville and get
employment and are happy and married and
have children there in Woodsville and
it's high it's high
post-secondary education is not the
highest you know need there it's to to
stay in my community to stay where our
master plan says they live there because
they want to live there they like the
environment they like the culture and
um and they're very successful so we
have many people there that are in
positions of business that don't have
college degrees
but more successful than I ever was
sure and follow up on that Mr chair and
you know certainly there are the Steve
Jobs and Bill Gates you know examples
both who attended college but but didn't
graduate and certainly found success
you know along the Malcolm Gladwell
they're right place at the right time
um as well and and and and interests but
um but yeah it it honestly it it only
took me um
um uh from the time uh representative
Murray was uh was called on and and
started to ask a question she was two
two words into it and I found the
Woodsville data right on the the U.S Ed
uh website and you said there's about
250 students in Woodsville high school
so that would be about
60 that are in the graduating class and
23 completed uh the FAFSA as of the 1231
so that includes the that's the full you
know number of number of people so it's
slightly below State average according
to Senator Khan's uh remarks but um but
I was I was you know wondering when when
we've got a
a nonpartisan State policy that that is
is still being you know uh presented by
the charitable Foundation by the
community college system by
apprenticeship New Hampshire and by
others of of 65 by 25 so 65 of the um of
of grown-ups in New Hampshire having a
post-secondary it doesn't have to be a
bachelor's degree or master's degree or
PhD but but um or even associate's
degree it could be a a valuable you know
career credential
um as um as our former Chancellor to the
community college system used to talk
about so eloquently
um uh that that the community college
system provides Pathways to careers not
necessarily through Associate's degrees
but how do we get there how do we get
there with with just a policy that that
like like you say mirrors what what
Woodsville is doing if that's only
achieving 23 out of out of 60 you know
in terms of you know FAFSA completion
how do we get to 65 by 25
with without having something more of a
stick and I wouldn't call it a uh it's
it's not a stick you're you're not going
to graduate Luke
um uh it's uh it's uh it's a it's a
stick saying you know what if um if if
you really don't want to find out find
out
that's all it's about finding out if you
really don't want to find out I'll write
you a waiver but uh but but we need you
and your folks to come down tomorrow
night to um to the Woodsville library
and and learn about the FAFSA how do we
make that happen how do we get to 65 by
25 without having a little more behind
this like what's in the current we're
not going to get the 65-25 we're there I
agree with that okay so that was Ross
cattell's deal
um
to a Hanover I don't want to live in
Hanover I don't want to live there
period for a lot of reasons
and those folks that are coming out of
Woodsville Haverhill area
I don't think we need to have another
mandate where our teachers are going to
our counselors or principals or
superintendent are going to have to run
down all these students we are trying to
run a school uh in a way that is best
satisfying that community and the
students within it and I think it's a
darn good job that they're doing
this is just throwing another mandate in
our NFA on our face and it's contrary to
local control
it's contrary to where we really should
be as a legislature this is a local
decision
um and I think it's being followed to
have that many students going off as you
know or FAFSA I would like to know what
the total number of kids are they're
going off to college from up there I
know there's a number of students in
there that don't want anything to do
with FAFSA that are already going to go
to school or are at post-secondary right
now I don't think pafsa is really an
indicator of how many folks are going
off to post-secondary education and I
don't think we should use it as an
indicator either
thank you further questions for
representative land see none oh yes
representative Balboni sorry thank you
and thank you for taking my question I
think you might have just answered it
though
um is that why you're repealing
um
193 E3 one oh
193 e one you're getting down to the
weeds yeah just curious
I I if you're talking about repealing
the FAFSA requirement no it's the
reporting the reporting of it
when I made all those reports as the
school principal or
I oftentimes wondered what's happening
with mfdoe
um
going into a pile never read uh we knew
we had worked with the parents and I
think we had accomplished what we were
supposed to do the kids were graduating
had that opportunity for an adequate
education and went on to jobs uh so I I
think this is an area that I question
even when this bill went forward and I
think most of us that were there at the
time said well we were able to kind of
uh make the absolute requirement if you
if you don't fill this thing out you're
not going to graduate we sideline that
with the option that you could have this
form I still think that's really kind of
inappropriate I think that it's uh it's
the state with their big hand getting
down on top of those districts where we
know what is best for our students and
we there I think that you you try to
find for me the schools which are not
doing dealing with FAFSA right now that
are not counseling that are not working
with students and Advising them that
this is an opportunity where you can
receive some dollars to help go to
post-secondary education I'm open to
that and that's what this bill does it
suggests that you know you can do it
through programs with parents at night
which is done I think most everywhere
you can have counselors dealing with
large groups and small groups that's
what should be going on at school during
the day you can embed this into your
various classes what you're teaching
certainly if you're talking Finance
literacy you should also be talking
about how do I come out of college you
know debt free hopefully
there's a lot of different ways of doing
this just like our social studies
teacher takes students down to these
colleges and checks them out in the
Boston area
um I can't help that most of the
students uh up my way do choose to go to
school out of state it's always greener
on the other side of the pasture for
these kids you know it's you know they
all come back most of them come back so
thank you
follow up just a quick follow-up so I
guess when you get into the reporting
you're saying that you you don't see the
value in in having that reported out
that if we're reporting if we're
reporting
did we deliver an opportunity for an
adequate education that's what I'd look
at all those indicators trying to
identify and report to our department of
education and there's a number of them
listed there you know were there how
many suspensions expulsions where you're
in the school I think that's important
to know
um how many students are going on to
post-secondary I think that's important
to know and I think it's even more
important to find out how many actually
go to post-secondary education and come
out and graduate all those other
indicators but I don't know how we can
say that this is a requirement or this
report impacts as an indicator that that
child has received an adequate education
has nothing to do with it
has absolutely nothing to do with it uh
the other indicators do come back and
relate to Advanced AP courses the re
revolve to the CTE programs that they've
taken uh it uh it provides that
information to the department that we
are doing this and students are
graduating and they have been delivered
that opportunity for an adequate
education
of Representative grassy
yes thank you Mr chairman
um being from Rochester I was a little
dismayed to hear that Senator Cam said
that you know Rochester has a 20
participation rate as far as Fabs is
concerned I know that they do the
parents nights
um by the way I have two children one at
the University of New Hampshire one at
Southern New Hampshire grandchildren
wanted two grandchildren who are
currently at UNH in Southern New
Hampshire and two children who graduated
from University of New Hampshire as well
so but
um the I know that they do parents
nights I know that they do Outreach to
the thing to the to the families as well
but 20 of of the people in Rochester
fill out these forms it seems it's a
problem we have one of the highest rates
of free and student and free and reduced
lunches in the state we have one of the
larger communities per capita of welfare
families in the state as well and it
seems that the the only way that these
kids are going to get to break that
cycle of poverty and I can't remember
who said it but the greatest equalizer
in this country is is a quality
education and
I know guidance counselors encourage
children to fill out these things
because I hear the complaints that all
the guide counselors do is push going to
college
but the thing is is that if we're doing
a lot of those things I mean I can't get
my school district to have to afford
buses to bring them here to the state
house so fourth graders I've got one
school coming out of the whole city of
Rochester because the PTO had to raise
the money this question didn't have the
money how do we fix it when we're
basically doing most of what's in your
Amendment and we're still not getting
the results
look at your adequacy bill now look at
the finance bill that we have going
through the senate in the house right
now that's we're going to fix some of it
right there but it's also it goes back
to leadership within the building
and Leadership and expectation and our
parents and our is the school on the
same wavelength are they aligned with
the aspiration that we want our child to
have this opportunity I'd also ask the
question in Rochester how many students
are going on to post-secondary education
how many students are going off to work
in the military how many students are
off to write out as a result of the CTE
program down there which are going off
with a an industrial recognized
certificate already
all those have to are part of that
equation it's just not FAFSA alone
there's a lot more to this which we We
Gather that information to have that I
I'd be very shocked if it's only 20 of
the kids in Rochester going off to
college
um yes representative
thank you I was wondering about the
reporting part of it too
um because I think some of the other
parts of it make sense to me of your
Amendment but with the the new and
improved internet program that the doe
has with the I report I mean it seems to
me that it would be
that that's where it would be visible
rather than uh before that actually came
online where they just kind of shoved it
in a file now we can look on and find a
whole lot of information about each
school and I think this might be an
important thing to to be there I think
that having this uh
the bill as maybe perhaps written by
this amendment it's very important to
have in place uh I for one though am a
little old school I as I think you are
or representative Tanner with those
statutes I want to have the book in
front of me uh when I'm talking with
folks it takes me usually 20 20 minutes
or so before I really get to the point
where I'm really starting to think on
that topic in depth
and I think that the eyeball to eyeball
communication rather than always on the
web is really important for students to
see somebody that's really
asking them the questions and having the
discussion with them regarding where are
you going what do you plan on doing
um are you taking as a freshman and
engaging as a freshman and sophomore the
types of courses that are going to lead
toward that school I think it doesn't
just start as a senior and as one of the
superintendents mentioned they have the
Freshman evenings and that's what they
do at CJ Academy as well and so it's and
that's why I am taking the trip now at
the end of that freshman year down to
Carolina with my grandkid to really
start looking
I think that's important so it's and
we'll find out yes there'll probably be
a need for a FAFSA absolutely
yes I that wasn't like my point my point
was
um because I totally agree with you I'm
old school and yes you know talking to
the kids being Hands-On with the kids
but the reporting requirement that
you've you've
um
deleted in on page two
um lines three through five the repeal
the reports I'm and uh I believe when um
representative Balboni talked uh asked
you the question you said you didn't
know what happened down at the state
department with these you know and I
agree we asked them to file things and
sometimes it's you know where to where
does it end up but I'm just saying
something like this might be an
important part of the I report where it
gives characteristics of each school I
have no objections to that the FAFSA
information is available on the federal
level it's just like represent luno was
able to say here's where Woodsville is
just like that because that information
is available but this is this bill
actually if you don't repeal that yes
sorry allows the doe to or actually
directs the doe I believe to
um or the schools to submit that report
um
to the DOE
I don't have that I see I don't believe
it's necessary you have to report this
stuff to doe I think that it's already
reported to the federal government so it
is available doe if they wanted they
could put it on the web they can get it
from the federal government and put it
on their I platform uh but I don't think
this is what you're doing is you're
telling that school district again
here's something else you got to be
handling and I there's a point where we
got to say we cannot be
asking these schools to do everything
that we think of that's necessary and
forget what you're doing down there
which is so very important uh I'd rather
say let the schools figure this out and
this is something we have to you know
that the diploma is not issued by the
state of New Hampshire this diplomas
issued by your local school district and
that school board is awarding that
diploma so there's where it belongs
right there uh
I guess I'll stop right with that
see no further questions thank you very
much you're welcome and I do not believe
there are any further cards for this uh
Amendment uh so I'll close the hearing
on this and we'll turn the gavel back
over to the chairman
thank you
you got five minutes so thanks thanks no
and I'll I'll make this this uh this
this quick too thank you very much Mr
chair so for the record Dave luno uh
representing people in Marymount County
District nine uh for folks that uh that
live in uh Hopkinton and Beau and I
always include Concord because Mel and I
are never going to give up on Concord
either and across the granite state
um but I'm here to introduce um
amendment number 1812h just to be clear
um really clear I support the the
statute that's currently in law so I'm
not supporting any of these amendments
but I did want to offer this one as a as
a third alternative since we're
dedicating this morning to uh to
speaking about non-germaine
um uh amendments to Senate bill 136. and
so um so really what uh What uh
Amendment 1812 does is um is adds one
more mechanism to uh that's available to
uh to principals to school districts in
this process so Senator Khan talked
about the three mechanisms that are in
place in the undercurrent statute
complete the FAFSA
complete the waiver
or the principal attests to that the
school has provided support and
assistance in informing students and
families to to how to uh how to complete
the uh the FAFSA
this creates a fourth
mechanism to um uh for principals to say
hey you know what we've achieved the
number and uh and that fourth mechanism
is by reaching an 80 FAFSA completion
rate as has been done in other states
that um uh that have enacted laws
similar to what we have on the book that
would take effect on July 1st and apply
to the school year that ends um uh in
June of 2024. so um so that's that's all
that that this does so for district set
that um that are providing
local Education Services to students and
families in terms of how to complete the
FAFSA what the FAFSA is where the
availability of information is and and
running that just like what we heard
from um uh from the superintendents in
Goffstown and Bedford and they're able
to achieve that 60 percent I mean that
80 percent
um uh success rate great they're done no
burden at all
um principal said you know what we're at
we're at 80 percent and which they can
find out varies the fact they don't even
need to chase down FAFSA paperwork or or
um uh you know letters from families
saying they've completed the FAFSA
because the information is available on
the US Ed website under federal student
aid and uh in fact if you if you just
look up online
um federal student aid and plug in the
name of your town Bedford New Hampshire
it's the first thing that'll come up you
click on it and you can download a
spreadsheet everybody knows I love
spreadsheets and uh and you look up
Bedford and tell you exactly the number
of students that that completed the uh
the FAFSA cumulatively by quarter so um
so you can you can you can find that out
and that's all with this amendment does
is uh is said using data reported by the
US Department of Education Office of
federal student financial aid for
December 31st of the of the current
school year so that includes current
students who are graduating as well as
students who had graduated in the prior
year and um and had had applied late so
so if that if that total number is um is
is 80 percent then um uh then you're
good and um and the the process
continues
um I I just also want to take a minute
since I've got the microphone here to to
say I just find it really hard to
believe that that we're looking at the
FAFSA as an as an optional equivalent to
going on to the middle military or going
on to
um in into the trades or becoming an
apprentice somewhere all the FAFSA is is
a piece of information giving you
something that you may not have are that
your family may not have already known
we all read media reports UNH really
expensive Community College systems
really expensive but that's different
than can my family afford it and that's
all the FAFSA is telling you can my
family afford it and and if I'm
seriously considering what do I want to
do for my career that might be a piece
of information that I want to consider
if I'm considering going on to college
or going into the military or using my
CTE degree to uh to enter you know an
apprentice uh ship program I might want
to know
if my family can afford College just as
part of that decision tree and that's
all the FAFSA that's all the FAFSA does
um uh you know uh you know we've we've
we've had politicians in the last
I don't know seven eight years say
ridiculous things like we love the
uneducated and frankly my parents never
ever said that to me and I hope none of
your parents ever said that to you
because that was something that was a a
more than aspirational it was probably
more aspirational for my family's
generation than it was for mine because
both my parents went to college my mom
had Advanced degrees
um so so there's an expectation that um
that at least I was going to work hard
and consider college and um and and of
course you know it would all depend on
on ultimately what um you know where you
get in and what you can afford and um uh
and you know that's an important thing
so so I'm I'm you know I I hope as
as a generation of current leaders in
New Hampshire and across other states
that were not giving up on that
aspirational ideal that you know what
college as well as other things too
helps people lift themselves up become
successful and I've heard my
constituents tell me become
tax paying citizens uh in the United
States in New Hampshire and in the
United States which helps all of us and
um and so that yeah that's what that's
what these opportunities as opposed to
you know other opportunities that may
not be so so successful uh for a person
or for a family
um and and college is among those
opportunities
so is military
so is CT and apprenticeship
um all are all are important this is
just part of the decision-making process
and um and all this all this amendment
does is just provide
um uh rewards a district and their
students if they're making the grade and
hitting that 80 bogey
um uh so um so thanks very much I'm
sorry to take up more time than than I
thought but I'll take a question or two
if it representative Moffett
thank you Mr I I and thank you Russell
for taking my question I have to ask and
thank you for letting me I was trying
not to like when we had the gifted
student bill in here
um which most of us recall one of the
arguments against the gifted bill which
is is not a law was that was an unfunded
mandate and now especially after hearing
the superintendents describe the
administrative concerns they had about
implementing the the bill that is coming
into effect on July 1st uh wouldn't this
be far more of an of a uh unfunded
mandate than than the gifted report
you know that's a that's a great
question I mean the um the the gifted
report not only requires the um school
districts school districts to uh to do
things but also requires the State
Department of Education to do things and
honestly I think there's there's there's
a real open question about uh about how
anybody is going to access these quote
best practices or whatever they're
called and what sort of utility they're
going to provide provide anybody at all
but uh but we certainly know from what
Senator Khan had had testified to that
where policies as the one we have in New
Hampshire comes into effect on on July
1st what that's what what how that has
manifested
um in terms of FAFSA completion in in
other states and information is power
and uh and that's that's something that
that benefits all of us and uh you know
and I I
empathize with with you know the um the
the testimony that we heard from from uh
superintendent Fournier in in Bedford
you know when he when he's saying that
you know what most of our families are
already completing this but as as he
also said he's not dealing with the same
challenges that a lot of other districts
across the state have and um and I like
to say in Hopkinton and and you know
what I was surprised I haven't heard
anything from our school board members
so I was surprised to hear that that
Mike Flynn the superintendent Hopkinton
signed on to this letter I I was at one
of the hobn school Mel and I were at a
school board meeting with Mike Flynn and
the board on Tuesday nobody mentioned
um uh this to us so I'm sort of a little
surprised
um to to see his name on there but you
know what
um ask Mike Flynn ask the superintendent
in Hopkinton how uh how school districts
20 minutes up the road are doing
um what's their FAFSA completion like
what's their um what what what's what's
Student Success like in um in their
district and uh and I'm talking about
Newport New Hampshire and not just from
Newport under the bus I've interviewed
students for MIT go you know coming from
Newport and frankly I've told Rick and
Mel know this that was one of the most
amazing college interviews I've ever had
because of what this student and their
family had to do
to get um to get him in a position where
um where he could succeed and I don't
you know I didn't follow you know the
student afterwards
um I do know that he did not make it
into MIT but this kid was going to be a
success and it was because they were
working hard to get the best education
for their student despite the resource
limitations in that District so you know
this is just something
despite it being an unfunded mandate
um that we're hearing is already being
done in Woodsville and in other places
the only thing that's not being done is
the final check off
and what the current statute does is
require the check off
so
um
what's what's
where we get value from what's being
done right now is when people attend
when students and their families attend
and they find out the answer
um about whether they can they can
afford college or not or maybe they just
find out you know what I don't even want
to bother trying
I don't even want to bother trying they
got to listen to
um uh neef or education Talent search or
Upward Bound or apprenticeship New
Hampshire or Mike turmmel from the
charitable Foundation talk about the
opportunities
in the context of other opportunities
too but at least find out
and
all that we're talking about
repealing here
not in the amendment that we're looking
at now but representative representative
Ladd's Amendment
is the check box and the check box is
the essential piece of this that says
look you at least you got to give it a
try and you know if you really don't
want to give a try there's a waiver
there's there's we can attest that we at
least offered it
and with the 1812 Amendment or most of
our kids are already doing it anyway and
we've you know Senator Khan used term
won the race
um so so I would really hope that
members of this committee and members of
the House and Senate will recognize what
we put into law a couple years ago
and
give it a chance
to run itself out give it a try see what
happens we can find out right away from
the federal student aid website how
that's manifesting in terms of
completion numbers you don't even need
to wait for principals to report
anything or or um or anything like that
you can look it up you can find it we
can find it out ourselves but let's just
give it a try and and uh sorry about the
long answer representative Moffett but
you know
but there we go represent cordelli thank
you Mr chairman um thank you
representative maybe you can correct my
understanding of what this amendment
says I'm looking at lines 11 through 14
in particular
the school district shell award a
diploma to the student and I take it it
means whose parents did not complete the
requirements of paragraph one which is
the waiver or the completion of the
FAFSA great
um
on two conditions first that the student
has met all the graduation requirements
secondly and
on line 12 and the completion rate
for that high school is at least 80
percent
so if the completion rate is not 80
percent does that mean that the student
cannot get that high school graduation
award no one of thank you for the
question Representative cordelli no uh
one of the other exemptions would would
have to have to uh or sorry one of the
other three mechanisms for for complying
with the with the with the current
statute would have to be true either
completing the FAFSA
or filling out a waiver
or the principal attesting that the
school has made a good faith effort to
uh to Pro provide information to on on
on the FAFSA so any of those three
things the this one is introducing a
fourth
um
saying that that and I think
representative cordelli characterized it
um perfectly well that uh that that if
the school district is already if FAFSA
completion in the school district is
already at 80 percent
um then um then then the principal can
attest to that and all the students are
have will have met this requirement
um obviously they have to meet other
graduation requirements in there and and
the the language in Roman three is
lifted from the other two ex you know
there's the paths of completion which
also says you have to complete all of
your other graduation requirements the
waiver and you have to complete it all
your other graduate requirements and the
school has provided the opportunity and
information and you have already you
know met all the other graduation
requirements
follow up thank you
um yeah I think maybe this
um conflict between
paragraph two which says that the
principal can attest to they try to get
the fast and FAFSA
um uh completion rate up and um uh so
forth
um
that says that if they do attest to that
the student can get a Graduation
requirement right but this is paragraph
three that says
the student cannot get a Graduation
requirement
if the completion rate is less than 80
percent so I think there's a conflict
between paragraphs two in the existing
law and paragraph three here in this
amendment
no no this this says um paragraph two so
um my apologies to the members in the
committee uh this is an amendment it
doesn't have what what represented
cordelli is looking at but paragraph two
if I were
let me step back the statute currently
has two paragraphs a Roman one and a
Roman two a Roman one says all students
must either as as part of a graduation
requirement complete the FAFSA or
complete a waiver right
paragraph Roman 2 says that if a student
has failed to meet
the the
um the requirements of paragraph Roman
one that the principal can attest that
that and I'm I'm I don't remember the
exact word good faith efforts have been
made to provide information to students
and their families with respect to FAFSA
completion did I sort of characterize
that pretty closely and then and and and
that and that the the principle can
attest to that provided the student has
met all the other graduation
requirements and then paragraph three is
a sen is taking another step saying
saying if the student has not been able
to meet the requirements of paragraph
one which is complete the FAFSA or
provide a waiver
then and and the
um the uh the principal
has can attest that 80 percent
um there's that there's an eighty
percent FAFSA completion rate in their
in their school and that the student has
met all of the graduation requirements
then then the student can graduate it's
it's mirrored the language from from
paragraph two uh which is the
alternative to the FAFSA and waiver
that provides and with this amendment it
would provide four mechanisms for um uh
for a student to to graduate in
compliance with the
um the FAFSA statute
further questions yes represent grassy
so just to make it quick if what I'm
understanding here is that if they meet
the requirements of 80 all the other
requirements are waived other than your
academic congratulations correct you've
satisfied the FAFSA required yeah
for the questions
represent Lucas
can you explain to me what's Magic about
80 percent and why if 80 of your kids
did it then
then it doesn't matter
um yeah I mean that's a that's a really
good question when when um when current
FAFSA completion Statewide uh is at
around 50 I believe that's what Senator
Khan uh um testified to and that has a
range all over the state from well below
50 percent to well above eight uh 50
including at 80 percent or above that um
that that 80 percent isn't isn't
attainable number
um uh in a lot of districts that it is
an aspirational number for many
districts whose students are not even
completing taking a look at completing
the uh the FAFSA but from what what has
been witnessed in other states Texas
Illinois and Louisiana that they have
seen Statewide completion Statewide
completion numbers go above 70 percent
with most districts or many districts
getting above 80 percent
um that uh that that that that that
seems like a reasonable number
um you know in terms of in terms of
looking at at good achievement rates and
it's certainly a number that that puts
the state a above our our the targeted
goal of 65 by 25 when uh when when
current
um uh higher education attainment is um
I I don't know what the current
um uh percentage is in New Hampshire I
think it's in the low 50s low 50 uh
percent it was 49 a few years ago and
now it's now it's right around 50 or 51
percent so so it puts us in the right
direction to get there
if if in fact the student that's the
high school student has met all
disciplinary type requirements nothing
there
all course requirements for graduation
why should the student not be allowed to
graduate from high school
um
that's that's a that's a really good
question and and I think there's there's
there's a lot of other things that that
contribute to whether or not a student
graduates
um from from high school including the
student's ability to attend the students
ability to be there and learn and in
this case it's um it's a student's
financial literacy in in understanding
what their um what their what
opportunities they may have in terms of
affording higher education and and um
and and
as a as a
as a society
whether that's the state of New
Hampshire in our economy or the the uh
the the you know our country as a whole
um we we base a number of policies on on
policy priorities that that we want to
see and and for instance one of them was
um years ago certainly way before my
time was uh was home ownership and how
home ownership was going to help expand
the middle class and provide greater
wealth opportunities for people all
across the countries and one of the ways
the United States
um uh provided a strong policy for home
ownership was to provide the um the
mortgage interest
tax deduction and um and that opened a
lot of doors for uh for people
um is it a good policy yeah I think home
ownership in the United States is a
really good policy and when we see
policies that that break that down or or
erode uh that then um then we get into
situations where where we're taking a
step back and uh in this case
you know taking it we we hear all the
time it's being debated at the federal
level right now in terms of um work
requirements associated with the the new
federal budget compromise uh along with
the um the um debt ceiling uh limit and
uh and we're hearing people say well you
know what people need to be working hard
they need to be taking initiative on
their own they need to be doing
something to improve their own success
in their own lives as opposed to relying
on um on us to do it and I'm just sort
of paraphrasing some things I think I've
heard in the news and um and completing
the FAFSA is another one of those things
it may help to dispel
um
a misinterpretation or or or bad
information that that or a bad
assumption I don't say bad information
but a bad assumption maybe that bad
assumption is you know what my family
can't afford College maybe that's a bad
assumption why is that well because I
read all the time I see all the time
that that the state of New Hampshire
doesn't contribute enough towards the
the university system in New Hampshire
enough State funds to the university
system New Hampshire or the Community
College of New Hampshire and both those
institutions have among the highest uh
tuition rates in the country there's no
way no way my family is going to be able
to afford me to go to college or that
I'm going to be able to go to college on
the um the the hourly rate that I make
bagging groceries at uh demoulas and um
and uh and I'm not saying anything
negative on demolis
let me finish this but but but this is
going to give new information to people
you know and that that may have been
operating Under a Bad assumption that
that college was was closed off to them
and and
you look at a lot of colleges and you
know again I'm thinking back to um and I
don't know I certainly don't know the
financial situation of the student I'd
mentioned up in up in Newport applying
to MIT but
first and family
um College acceptance is a really
important thing
um you know I think it'd be it was
probably important for their family but
I think it's important for us as a
country too because once um
once that Band-Aid is is how are we how
do we talk about it earlier once that
once that cycle is broken then future
Generations do go to college and and um
or do attain post-secondary
um certificates and are in the workforce
and are paying taxes and are successful
and they raise families and just like
what Senator Khan said it's good for the
economy it's good for families and it's
good for the workforce and and we don't
all have to agree that that staying on
getting associates degree from nhci were
will representative Moffett has has
taught for many years where I serve on
the board
um is necessarily the right thing for
everybody nor is going to UNH nor is
going to MIT or or any other things but
understanding what my options are is
huge is of huge importance and and when
you're when you're basing it on
assumptions it's not good and especially
the assumptions that that that could be
created based on you know the
information here in New Hampshire on on
College tuition
um uh you know I I was I was surprised I
mean I've been on the nhti board for I
think close to 25 years and and when
Senator Khan said and I wrote it down
that um that the Community College of
New Hampshire can be at no cost
to people who qualify for Pell and
that's absolutely true I've always known
that but I never really connected
um that that that you know what I don't
know if I qualify for Pell unless I fill
out the FAFSA
and then when I find out my family
qualifies Propel wow
New Hampshire community colleges are
free
so that's why
okay my question to you is that
a student
not complying with paragraph one
schools FAFSA record fifty percent sixty
percent below 80 percent
student received early admission
at the beginning of the senior year
is that student not going to graduate
no no no the the the student will either
get
um either have a waiver from their
family or not participating at all okay
or or the principal says you know what
we did just fine for this and and you
know we provided the information the
information that that you've got on
there that in your in in your Amendment
representative blood that um that that
has been provided so uh to the to the
student and their family so yes that
student is going to graduate we have no
information Senator can't talk to those
no information of students being denied
graduation but having this stick out
there has compels more families to at
least find out the answer to um uh to
this and and you know that we're we're
not I mean I know New Hampshire other
than other than the primary we don't
like to be the first in the nation on
much and we're not the first in the
nation on this one either there's at
least four states that that have done
this for years now and um and you know
it'll be sort of you know lay it out
yeah these are red states too and
they're seeing good things as a as a
result of um as a result of the policy
as we have it on the books right now
um uh no the student's not going to be
denied uh graduation if the student
hasn't completed the FAFSA I'm I'm
surprised that they uh that they
necessarily completed a college
application I mean I'm not I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but I I think
the the you know the other part of the
the sort of the the connection here is
is if you don't complete the FAFSA
you're not you're you're not completing
college applications either whether
that's the the the
um the the
automatic application that that you can
have for Community College or if it's an
application at Dartmouth where you've
got
um a uh you know where you're in early
decision uh candidate and and
yeah and there there may be some people
that that
live in some towns across the state that
recognize the situation that they're in
where there's where there's a tremendous
amount of family money and there's no
way I'm going to be getting
um financial assistance it's going to be
expected that my family contributes 100
percent but that's not a that's not why
the statue is on the books right now and
it's not why we're doing this
um
yeah I want uh I want those kids to go
on and be successful too
but but I'm less worried about those
kids than I am
um you know the kid in Newport
and and making sure that
that
they complete the FAFSA they know Eyes
Wide Open what they
what their opportunities are whether
it's College whether it's military
whether that's apprenticeship whether
that's
um you know what what they've you know
continuing what what they've learned in
CTE but eyes wide open and and um and
there's nothing inconsistent uh with
with going on to one of New Hampshire's
community colleges and going into the
trades because that's one of the areas
that our community college is constant
in fact the University of New Hampshire
also provides some um uh uh trade I mean
there's an HVAC program right down in
UNH in Manchester so
um so but
you don't go into that you don't go to
UNH Manchester uh unless you complete
the FAFSA
you go to university Maine
without complaining of FAFSA my
granddaughter did that early admission
full ride
didn't complete FAFSA
yeah so you know I I just you know I
think this is just you know heavy-handed
on all students and a student that did
not want to complete that FAFSA didn't
need to complete that FAFSA
the one went to Texas A M never
completed a FAFSA one that went to
Elmira never completed a thousand
just recently me I we did it for St
Lawrence
so I you know you know I I I don't want
to I it's hard for me to to I mean I can
certainly speak in the generalizations
and what what the what the statute was
intended for when you're talking about
specific students uh like you're like
you know your daughter or grand
grandkids I don't wanna I'm not gonna
get into that with you in a public in a
public forum uh like this and and
whether or not you know a college
um uh
you know what what a college may have
been looking for uh in terms of um you
know income or whether whether Student
Financial Aid was provided for by the
college I know there's a number of
colleges that do provide uh full need
and and have need blind uh admissions
MIT being one of them and um and they'll
provide
um uh student
um Financial need for families that are
earning North and I believe the number
is is is above four hundred thousand
dollars right now you'll still get some
some student need
um and I know that's a high number when
when talking about median household
incomes generally in in New Hampshire
but but you know it may be something
that that that some high earners in New
Hampshire might be surprised to know
that that uh that they qualify for um
for um federal financial aid or or even
more importantly
financial aid from the the institution
that they that they that they go into
and a lot of this financial aid come in
the form of Grants as opposed to loans
uh this could very well be something
that helps reduce New Hampshire's
student loan debt by by opening the door
for more students to uh to receive
direct grants from the institutions they
attend
um uh yeah you know
they're all institutions including the
the university system community college
system Tim Allison is in here quite a
bit
um who uh who directs the the community
college system uh foundation and um and
I think they'll all be the first to
admit that one of the things that has um
has opened the doors to so many students
um to attend college particularly first
in family to attend college is the
generosity of alumni and
um and you know I think if if if
colleges are going to protect that that
Revenue source of the generation of
alumni to contribute to to college
scholarship foundations than than these
institutions better be strong at making
sure that we're providing the need where
it's needed and um and that's one of the
things that the FAFSA helps to ensure
that uh that that that that
you know that
based on answering the the questions and
the information that's that's provided
um uh through through you know tax
information
um that that that comes over directly
now uh apparently that that that a
student's need is going to be
demonstrated and um and Foundation
dollars are going to be applied where um
where they're needed thank you are there
any other questions from the committee
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I just wanted to follow up
uh quickly on a question that the chair
posed about
um the specific situation and whether or
not a student would graduate you know
early graduation or early acceptance to
a college not for the nav FAFSA
um and I know you've said that they
would not be held back because of the
waiver but I've looked at it I don't see
anything that would require that waiver
so would you agree that it would be at
the discretion of the principal whether
they would graduate or not so the waiver
um thanks thanks for the question
um uh the waiver
um can be can be completed by the family
uh and um and you know I think if if
we're in a situation where where uh
my family was so concerned
that that about about our son or
daughter not attending not being able to
um to to
go to college early decision because we
didn't complete a FAFSA and we're beside
ourselves that that that our kids may
not graduate that you know what we we'd
fill out a waiver and do it but if we
didn't let's say that that I just had a
refusal of filling out waivers
um that the principal then could um
could either fill out a waiver or a test
that that
the school had provided information to
the student and their family about FAFSA
completion
or if they didn't do that
and they had
80 percent or nor or more uh perhaps the
completion rate that the prince
principal could attest to that as well
so so I I think there's there's
the first mechanism is complete the
FAFSA
and the other three mechanisms are
waiver
good faith support and assistant
or with this amendment
eighty percent FAFSA completion rate in
the preceding year
um that that
and and
you know and you know I I don't think
anybody is necessarily more
more expert at least as far as you know
today on the efforts that have that are
being done by neef
and others across the state and um and
and what's been going on in other states
and there's just no evidence of um of of
anybody under that circumstance having
their high school diploma withheld so so
yeah I mean that's
I don't think that's something that's
that that we've seen further questions
from the committee
not seeing thank you very much thank you
Mr chair
okay are there any other pink cards for
this amendment
not see any thank you very much we will
close this hearing and uh
basically what we're gonna have to do
now is we're going to go the next step
is that we're going to have to take
action these two bills but we'll
probably have a caucus prior to that
yeah well lunch is important
so let's take you know if we
were looking at we're at 12 35 right now
so if we have an hour fullness can we
also caucus in that same time
yes I would think so
let's do that
so then we come back 135 or 1 45
yeah let's let's come back at 145 once
we do the action on this bill then all
these people subbing today can can lead
because we're just going to be doing the
organization or subcommittees
145.
James Wilcox
foreign
is to deal with the tubules that we have
for exacting 136 has amended possibly by
one of those three non-germaine we heard
this morning
and then 213 which is a bill that deals
with social media and Career Technical
education
um so what I'd like to do first is
explain to the public that
we have there's going to be some
discussion Within These two bills which
we have coming up the bills have to be
out of that this committee today as they
have to be reported by Thursday and
quite truthfully I don't think a lot of
us want to come back uh Wednesday uh to
work on this
I got a couple guys from that
um so
um we're gonna have to deal with it
today one way or the other then what we
have following that is that we have uh
bills which we have retained which there
will be very little if any discussion on
the particular topics what we're trying
to do is just one thing only is to
discern whether we're going to have a
subcommittee for a particular bill or
not have a subcommittee and wait to take
up that bill during a committee of the
whole
uh later on next fall so the
subcommittees we would identify there's
definitely several bills here which we
can combine into one subcommittee but we
just don't have the workforce here to do
a subcommittee in all 20 bills and do it
properly
so with that we will be doing that
occur yeah and then we do have four
bills which we've received from the
Senate which this group's going to have
to decide whether we concur non-concur
or request a committee a conference uh
that we can also do if we have to by way
of the web as we've done it oftentimes
before that's not a public process it's
one of which we do internally with the
committee
lastly we are in the process of trying
to update this group right here on where
we are with our finances in terms of
education for the upcoming biennium
there's been a number of recent changes
including today with Senate finance and
that we're we just need be all on top of
where the education funding formula is
and how it's going to impact various
educational programs
so let's get on with with the executing
of the bills here first and get that
done with we want to look at
um the 136 bill for Senate bill 136.
this bill prohibits the employment of
volunteering or of of a revoked or
suspended educator
um in in a school district
and so I need to have a before we can
get into any Amendment we need to have a
motion on the bill itself
represent Cordell you ready to make a
motion I am uh I am I am and that would
be ought to pass is there a second on
the opt pass on 136
okay we have a second from represent
Milo what's it down there okay thank you
so with that
um
is there any discussion from the maker
of the motion
and none I'm sure we'll have plenty of
discussion on other topics
representative same okay with that then
I'm going to recognize
um
rec center for representative Noble
promotion
um I move wait we're doing yours correct
I move uh to pass on Amendment
1744h I'll second that
okay so we have Amendment 1744h this is
a
Amendment we heard this morning it deals
with uh the issue of FAFSA the free
application for federal student aid
assistance which is uh an issue dealt
with by the high schools uh we had three
uh hearings this morning uh I'm not
going to discuss any further seeing I I
presented it and uh I think everybody in
the committee knows where I am
Is there further discussion from members
of the committee on that
sure yes representative Luna
thank you thank you very much Mr chair
um while I think 1744
it helps to you know codify what some
districts are doing right now I I think
it um it it it doesn't move the needle
uh in um with many of the districts who
are currently
the lad amendment to 136.
no this is the lad amendment to 136.
yeah the motion was made by Noble second
in my lad but we're talking about 1744.
that's right 1744. yes that that um in
some districts that are actually
doing this and like I say some districts
are doing this but in in some that are
doing it right now like representative
grassy's district
um there it's only achieving a about a
um FAFSA completion rate Which is far
short of of I think any reasonable
Benchmark in less than half of what the
uh what the state average achievement
rate is so um so
um I'm I'm inclined to want to leave the
um the the current Statute in place give
it a chance to um to perform it hasn't
even come into effect
um in fact doesn't even go into effect
until uh until July and give some
districts a time to uh to see how it uh
see how it works out
further discussion on it yes
representative
what we're really concerned about is
making sure that all students are
exposed to the FAFSA have
um know what what their benefits are
from it all of that this makes sure that
all students are exposed to it if there
are districts
whose parents if who are going through
all of this and they're not having a
bigger application rate I would argue it
was because the parents didn't want to
and I have spoken to numerous parents
from um
multiple Parts both very poor and
sufficiently
I won't say very rich but sufficient
um who just absolutely disagree with
having to give any of their personal
information over the consider it a
violation of their privacy and
unfortunately you can't just apply and
get an answer you have to actually
choose a college
and that college gets your information
so you're in private information is out
there and what I have heard is that they
just don't want to do that so forcing
them to do that and holding graduation
over their children's head in order to
force parents to
um
provide private information I think is
totally not what the state should be
doing
further discussion
I'd like to say one thing about that the
Department of Education has developed a
FAFSA
waiver form
that form is simply a form in which the
student or the parent of the student if
the student's not 18
signs the form goes nowhere
it does not go to doe so will not be
part of the I platform at all there's
nothing in statute says that this is
part of the I platform as it's been
alluded to earlier it just stays right
there probably on file somewhere in the
school district or the school or the
school district office
it's basically in alignment with what we
heard from the superintendents today and
we know there's well over 20
superintendents assigned a letter a memo
that representative Noble provided us
that states that they believe the
process is is good we need to let
students know that FAFSA is a process in
which they can receive Monies to help
support their efforts to go to college
we all agree on that its problem is that
and it's this this amendment Essence
data ensures that the students will see
this form and have it communicated to
them and allows the school districts to
local school district to continue doing
what they're normally doing in terms of
this process of informing students these
graduation high school students
graduating of the the the the the the
processes that that are taken to fill
the form out so they have counselor to
help fill the form out they have family
Information Center sessions at night
time or during the day available to them
it's offered through teachers at the
school many different ways of doing this
and quite successful at that the process
comes the the conflict comes is that
um
when we start telling them that you will
not graduate if you haven't jumped all
these hoops and it takes a school
principle a lot of effort and time to
chase down people to get permission for
them or get their signature on this form
right here
and that's all just another requirement
and so you get the signature the parent
so be it you know you can't get a
telephone conversation essentially like
that and say parent says yes you have to
have the parent come and sign the form
or give it to a student and bring it
back well everybody knows getting
permission slips home even from
elementary kids regarding a field trip
can be a devil of a Time
um and uh to get something like this and
we don't even get the application forms
back for free and reduced in the high
school kids and we know we're shallow
numbers in terms of determining free and
reduced and poverty in these schools
just resulted that's why we had Medicaid
direct which we're going after
so we have many school districts here
that came and said we we support the
process of FAFSA it's a very important
step it shouldn't be part of what we
require in order to get out of school it
should be achievement and performance in
terms of those 20 to 24 credits of
course is required
so the amendment does not stop the
process as far as FAFSA communication
what it does stop though is that threat
of graduation has been taken off the off
the off the statute throughout the books
so I think this is a a good step forward
and in line with what schools are doing
and supports them and ensures the FAFSA
will be provided to students this bill
ensures that
represent cordelli uh thank you
um and I believe the chairman lad you
mentioned the waiver would not
necessarily go anywhere
um it it could be as we heard from the
Department
um they don't know what happens to it it
can be filed in the drawer it could be
shredded it could be anything and I
think the same applies for the current
law paragraph two about
if the parent does not sign the waiver
and there's no FAFSA filed the principal
can attest to they made a good for Faith
effort but as I pointed out a test
to who to what there's nothing about
what happens
um uh does you know the superintendent
call up and others superintendent and
say uh you know I attest to the fact
that we tried
um there's nothing in statute about what
this means so I think it's a a toothless
meaningless exercise
further discussion representative luno
sure thanks I you know I think pretty
much both the FAFSA waiver form and the
uh the you know the principle of testing
to the fact that a good faith effort was
take was uh made by the district to
inform parents and students could easily
be done and put into the students um you
know file of record which would have
other compliance with graduation
requirements as well so I think that's
pretty simple and to say that it has to
be spelled out in um you know black and
white in statute is a little bit crazy
um uh given that I think
um it's it's pretty easy to make sure
that these things are connected with
them with the students performance
through through school
thank you for their discussion
yes represent Lucas
I just wanted to um
repeat what one of the superintendents
asked don't put superintendents in a
position of withholding graduation from
a student based on a decision of their
parents
thank you further discussion from the
committee
Adam clerk would you please call the
roll
this will be we're talking now the
amendment 1744.
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative leckis yes
representative desamani
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Moffett yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Heath
no
representative Tanner
no Representative luno no
representative Murray no
representative grassy no
representative hall now representative
Balboni
no
representative cascadden
no representative Damon no chairman lad
yes
10 years 10 days
okay the amendment is not approved
girls open for further discussion
representative
please uh yes thank you chairman
um I would ask you for a motion on the
next Amendment which is uh
1396. yeah so I'd like to make a motion
of ought to pass on 1396 H
this is the noble Amendment
um
did I hear something second okay thank
you very much uh comment from uh the
maker
yes uh
unfortunately this uh this just com just
deletes the whole program which we have
however I believe that we do not need to
have the threat of graduation
requirements for any student who has
accomplished all those 20 to 24 course
requirements while in high school
has no disciplinary problems however
hasn't completed the FAFSA or paralleled
the requirements and FAFSA by having a
written notice something such as this
signed off and the only other
possibility yes is that the principal
could say yep
they they they get this exception I
think to put this heavy weight over top
of students and put something like this
in statute is absolutely incorrect
um the the need to threaten people with
loss of graduation
um there are a number of students that I
know of and had one in my own family
that had early admission to a division
one School uh early in the school year
in November totally paid for by the
school that she was going to did not
need FAFSA did not complete a FAFSA form
but under this situation right here
would have to complete a FAFSA form
doesn't make any sense to me
uh representative Noble comment
I agree with chairman lud
thank you comments from the committee
representative Paul thank you and um
this is for representative Vlad of chair
lad sorry
um when you said she didn't have to
complete a form she could have signed a
waiver though right
foreign
yeah she could have signed a waiver but
why would she want to sign a waiver and
why would her mother want to put all
this information down if she had a full
boat scholarship waiting for her based
upon one thing only and one thing only
graduation from high school
it isn't it just follow-up follow isn't
it just a check mark like I weighed my
you know that you don't have to give the
information doesn't she have that right
the way the bill there has to be some
kind of a sign up by her or a check by
her or the parent
um
this has nothing to do with the
achievement of a student in high school
you know when we graduate students we
graduate them based upon their
achievement and accomplishment of the
what they're able supposed to be able to
do and
she had shown everything that she was
supposed to do academically and
athletically
I see no reason why she has to jump this
other hurdle
representative cordiello
yes uh
thank you um I don't know if you all had
a chance to read the letter Dear
honorable members of New Hampshire
education committee from
20 plus superintendents I find this very
persuasive
um coming from so many superintendents
themselves mentioning phrases like
locals to control maintaining local
control which we all agree is very
important there's also the phrase
several times unnecessary government
overreach here but one of the things
that really strikes me
is where they say uh
this requirement it sends the message
that college is the only pathway after
graduation in a time when trade schools
are in desperate need of a Workforce
what message is this sending to those
for whom college is not their first
choice and I am concerned about what
messages is sending
because and I come from from this as a
former College instructor
whose children go to colleges and Co you
know it's not for everyone though and we
have the trades we have several of the
uh those who testify made comments about
you know how well those are going to the
trades do but I think sometimes in high
schools we're sending this more and more
we're sending this message that
college is the way to go and I think we
should be encouraging also that some
some kids are are more suited to going
to not going to college and and so
that's why
requiring this
sends a mixed message so
that's why I think that we should not
require it further discussion represent
Luna
sure thank you very much Mr chair no I
mean I'm not confused by uh by buying
this at all I don't think it sends a
mixed message especially when uh when
when many of our uh of our state
um
um colleges and community colleges
provide
degrees that um that that for for people
to take into the trades as well as
non-degree high-value certificates for
people to uh students to take into the
trades and can also supplement that
trade education with business education
so not only do they end up working in
the trades but they may actually be able
to own and operate a um you know a small
business in that area so I'm not
confused at all by by that and secondly
I'm not at all confused by the FAFSA
waiver form which simply says and and
someone put a copy
um on the table
um by executing below I acknowledge that
I'm a student over the age of 18 or a
pound of Guardian of a student who's
under the age of 18 and I acknowledge
that I understand that the free
application for federal student aid
isn't and I've chosen not to file an
application and and I I understand this
may seem onerous to some but the only
information that's required on this form
is the student name
an email or a phone number
a signature
and believe it or not the date
that's it
and um
um you know and
you know there's not a lot being asked
of here I don't find it to be confusing
but that's me and um and you know I I
certainly think that that most students
and families in New Hampshire would
probably not find this form confusing
either thank you representative D Simone
thank you Mr chair I just looked at the
FAFSA waiver form and one of the areas
that it does not include is if a student
under the age of 18 who is emancipated
or married it does not re uh enter that
in as a legal signatory to make this
waiver form work
so I just don't think that that is
really complete enough to do this I I
see no reason for it thank you just so
everybody knows that the waiver form was
dropped off at the conclusion at
lunchtime by uh uh Mr Appleby who was
here observing he dropped them and he
had six copies so they were just left
right there
uh representative Miler and then
represent Belcher oh thank you Mr Mr
chairman we've spent a lot of time on
this issue frankly a lot more than I
thought we were going to spend on it but
it's it's important
um what we're what we're talking about
here is providing an opportunity for
students to um decide what they want to
do
and to understand that there are there
is financial aid available
we're not just college and I wanted to
score that
I mean if you spend any time in a
community college
you'll begin to realize that there there
are opportunities here
for students and what this is really
about is post-secondary education
it's about post-secondary education and
the creation of a Workforce here
one of the things that I was impressed
with which I never made the link until
this morning
was that when students are
graduating from high school
the next decision they make is going to
shape the rest of their life
and whether it's going to go to a trade
school whether it's going to go to
college wherever it's going to be it's
going to impact the rest of their life
and it seems to me that this requirement
to at least look at an option
of some financial assistance for the
rest of their life
this is this is an important thing to
have take place here
and I think that that we've talked about
the waivers
people don't have to participate it's
very clear you don't have to participate
but it also provides an opportunity for
a family to have a conversation
about what they want to do
and in some cases that conversation
might not ever take place
so I I just think that this uh the bill
that we currently have on the books is a
very important one for the future of a
graduating senior thank you
for representative represent Belcher and
then representative cardelli
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
speak for a moment to the to the waiver
concept and we do know with this bill
there's three ways to achieve to get
past it to get your degree
um but a lot has been made of the waiver
and a lot has been made of well what if
you don't want to sign the waiver
and I think it's important for us to
remember that
the restrictions that exist within our
constitution both federal and state are
restrictions on what the government is
allowed to do
and we don't get to tell people
oh just sign here even if you don't want
to they get to say no they get to set it
up yours whatever they want
they get to do that and we don't get to
tell them otherwise and the idea that
we're going to withhold a degree or for
those who would argue we won't actually
withhold it we'll just jump through some
hopes and give it to them anyway well
then what's the point
thank you represent cordelli uh thank
you uh I would just point out that uh I
think there is nothing preventing
families from looking at this now and
having a conversation about Direction
without the government telling them that
they have to
further discussion
yes represent cascadden um in written
just in reviewing the RSA 193 26 8.
it starts with that that opening
paragraph that everybody must
but as you read through the parts of the
law it's if applicable
so families don't want to fill out the
fashion they don't fill out the fashion
so it's if applicable so I I don't see
the need for anything else
for the discussion represent leckis
if the bill doesn't actually do anything
why do we have it I mean the law
um because you heard with the
superintendent said we never stop
anybody from graduating
and I can tell you that my best friends
my daughter's best friend her mom
wouldn't fill out anything for anything
anything permission whatever she would
not have filled this out but the school
knew her and they would have just no
problem well why do we have it if we're
just no problem if we're not going to
keep anybody from graduating anyways
like the superintendent said
there's no point in this law to begin
with we might as well get rid of it
represent Damon
it's my understanding that the purpose
of this law is so that students who
would not otherwise
recognize the benefit the potential
benefit
of filling out the FAFSA and finding out
that they've in fact could afford to go
to college
would have the opportunity of that
learning I think we're asking
people to make a very small effort
to if they don't want to fill out the
FAFSA to sign the waiver form
so that all individuals
can determine whether it is a reasonable
pathway for them to go to higher ed
I had a number of personal experiences
in my career counseling nutrition and
health issues with teenagers
and I am going to just particularly note
an experience with a young woman very
very bright
not at all intending to go to college
and I got to know her quite well over a
course of a couple years
and along the way said so why aren't you
considering College
my family can't afford it
I had a collaborative relationship with
her mom and I persuaded her mom to fill
out the paths very reluctantly because
she was in fact concerned that family
privacies would be violated
I was a PhD now she is benefiting other
people
when she was two years into college she
called me and said I just want to let
you know my mom filled out the FAFSA for
my brother today
it's so little that we are asking people
to do to help folks succeed
represent Des Moines
thank you Mr chair since 1769 when
Dartmouth opened its doors people have
been going to college and figuring out a
way to pay
they can get scholarships career
guidance counselors in the school guide
them to where they can apply there are
books this thick that I used with my
children when they applied for
Scholarships in order to go to college
and I I don't see why we should have
FAFSA that says if you don't fill out
this form you're not going to graduate
so forget about college
further discussion from the committee
representative I'm sorry Mr chair but
one more comment
um several years ago
this committee uh supported
high school students taking the SAT
scores that was new to the state
and one of the reasons why we did that
is that one the other
tests that they were taking was really
taking Fair lightly and kids didn't
really like to take it
but one of the motives for the SAT
was that students who take the SAT and
score higher than they thought they
would
gives them an indication says hey maybe
this is for me to go on to a
post-secondary school
and when they took those tests what we
did find is that more kids did in fact
decide to go on to post-secondary
education I view this form in a very
similar kind of a way as those kids
taking the SAT and realizing that there
is a pathway for them that they might
not have thought about
so that's why I will not support this
OTP
yes represent Balboni yes thank you Mr
chair I'm on the same lines it hasn't
even gone into effect yet so we don't
know what what will happen so I would
rather wait and see what happens I mean
it could have a good effect nobody knows
further discussion from the committee
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
please call the rule
thank you
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Moffett yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Myler
representative Heath nope
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Murray no
representative Crosby no representative
Hall Nell representative Balboni no
Representative cascabin no
representative Damon no chairman LED yes
10 years 10 days
thank you so the motion fails uh do we
have another motion represent luno I'll
I'll move um
oh you're you're not going to bring your
Amendment up okay
but I think you're
we already have that yes I was just
curious to know if you're going to go
with uh 1812. you're welcome okay we
have a motion on the table the motion is
to
OTP on SB 136.
for those in the public this is a bill
prohibiting the employment or
volunteering of a revoked or suspended
educator
much different than FAFSA
so here we are back with the original
motion
the motion is ought to pass is there any
further discussion on this bill
yes reps yeah go ahead
represent yeah just just reviewing the
bidding a bit um I just want to make the
word no other amendments on 136.
that were offered or anything like that
back when I mean I just wanna
I don't believe we had any other
amendments on it it's clean it's 136.
it's it's just clean it had one sponsor
on it from the Senate and that was it
yep
further discussion representative
Belcher did you have a yes Mr chair I
just wanted to bring up a small concern
I had briefly about the the nature of
adding of including private sector
schools in this bill because I can
reasonably foresee a future given what
we know about cancel culture where a
student or a rather a teacher could be
suspended for relatively trivial and
non-education and non nothing that would
make them a danger or what not to any
students who might then want to move on
to the private sector and this bill
would therefore prohibit that from
happening under this uh under this
proposed bill
is there any discussion represent Tanner
I would just say that my understanding
and my hope would be that somebody
that's suspended or loses their
credential
does so
for a very important reason because
that's their livelihood
and they're professional and uh it isn't
done lightly at all
foreign
if a person for example wanted to work
or teach in a private school
that did not require a credential this
bill would not prevent that person from
doing so because it talks about a
a revoked or suspended educator and then
it also says
um
not hire any individual whose credential
issued by the department is currently
suspended or revoked but if it doesn't
like to me there's a little ambiguity in
terms of if a person want to come out
and work as be employed as a
on in a job that did not require
the credential
uh maybe that's something we need to
discuss here but uh
I thought it also said that they
couldn't be hired as a volunteer which
kind of to me indicates that uh it you
don't it doesn't have it isn't a direct
correlation to your credential it's
working with children and one of our
most important things is to keep Kids
Safe whether it's private school public
school camps
um and uh I just think that that uh it
it goes beyond saying that that we
should have this as
um as many under this umbrella as
possible
further discussion this representative
my question and it has to do with what
is going on today
um if a teacher
will not do what her administrator
has said that she had to do would she
not were he not be
um potentially have their
certification
taken away word
I don't know it's not Disobedience but
insubordination whatever at any rate and
I'm thinking of for instance things that
we've dealt with already this year and
last year
if the superintendent says which some of
them do
you will be teaching Dei in all of your
classes not as a curriculum but you will
work it in to everything and a teacher
says no I'm not going to do that or the
school says you will lie to parents when
they ask you specifically
about
what names your child goes by at school
unless you unless you have documentation
no no no no I think it's totally
uncalled to recognize you no no I I
don't think what she's saying and what's
going out paints teachers in such a bad
light or or puts the thought out there
the of the deception the teacher that
this is going on then unless you have
proof of that I don't think we should
entertain sitting here and listening to
it I I excuse me but we have had
teachers testify that they were asked to
do that and they did not want to and so
my question is if they refuse to do that
will they have their licenses revoked
and then not be able to get another job
cut in right here the we're talking
about revoking or suspending a
credential
I for the topic we're talking about I
would question whether the certificate
um so uh attorney Fenton
do you have a second for a question
actually
I didn't really need to go down this
road yeah
we know we have the code of ethics and
code of you know uh conduct
um
the topic we're talking about here is
refusing to teach something
that may be in your curriculum or your
that's against your conscience is that
something that's worthy of yanking a
certificate
good afternoon for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education to answer your
question
no the short answer is is no
um the department has not taken action
in that instance that would be
insubordination that would be an
employment issue and there is a
significant distinction between
employment issues and credentialing
issues and there are a host of things
that happen at a school district
that fall outside of the Department's
purview
and I can think of
you know dress code issues not showing
up on time for your job classroom
management issues curriculum issues
those are are not those do not fall
within this document which was passed by
this legislative body in House Bill 210
in in 2016 or 2017.
this document here is very narrowly
construed
it was designed by House Bill 210 to be
very narrowly construed and the rules
were written to really address instances
where educators are having inappropriate
relationships with students and that's
the type of behavior that the department
is able to say we don't want this
individual who is harming a child in
District a to then go into District B
but other issues that fall within
employment classroom management
not showing up on time those are all
employment issues and the department
stands back and those will be handled at
the local level thank you very much for
answering my question thank you for the
opportunity I appreciate it
while we have attorney Fenton there is
there any other yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here for this um
so we've heard the precedent what
currently happens do you are you aware
of anything in statute that would
prevent a hypothetical future
Administration from changing their
executive policies such that a teacher
could be or could lose their credential
under such circumstances is it a
theoretical possibility legally
you know is it possible sure anything's
possible but the way it's structured is
you have the law which was House Bill
210 and that changed RSA 21n9 and that
set out four parameters four principles
that the code of conduct had to entail
and based on that there that law also
required rule making Authority and
that's how this document came to be and
I apologize for the battered copy here I
I thought I had a newer copy
representative Tanner I'll get you copy
um
and that's how the rules came out now
could the rules be be opened and
Rewritten of course it could be that's
part of the process every 10 years the
rules are opened however
and now could the rules be be opened and
Rewritten under a new Administration yes
they could be
the way they are written now
um we do have
um something called administrative gloss
an administrative glass is something
that I learned from the Attorney
General's office when I started at the
Department of Education which is how a
department has interpreted prior rules
in the past
to carry forward now how that is
enforced
I guess is anyone's guess but I know
that that is something that we've
learned from the Attorney General's
office is in theory a new commissioner
can't come in and just suddenly say I
know this is how the rules have been
interpreted in the past and we're going
to go in a different direction and so
that would be my answer to your question
is I would I would argue administrative
gloss has dictated how the department
has interpreted those rules previously
and that should carry forward
if I may just to follow up on the other
issue that just came up because I think
it's directly pertinent to this they're
argument about a possible future where a
teacher could lose their license for for
instance insubordination refusing to do
something that they're um that they're
told or required if I could just for a
moment read from the uh school policies
from my school district the Paul School
in Wakefield under privacy when it comes
to transgender students the board
recognizes the student's right to keep
private once gender status or gender
non-conforming presentation at school
information about a student's
transgender status legal name or gender
assigned to birth may also constitute
confidential information School
Personnel should not disclose
information that may reveal a student's
transgender status or gender
non-conforming presentation to others
including parents
would you categorize that as possibly
requiring parents to be dishonest to
parents
yeah you know because if we're talking
credentials credentials
are not related what you were saying
right there that would be an employment
issue yeah that's an employment issue
100 every school district is going to
have their own policies for employment
purposes
um I mean the example I always give is
I'm licensed to practice law by the
state of New Hampshire I'm employed by
the state of New Hampshire
and there are a ton of State policies
that I could violate which would affect
my employment but do those rise to the
level of affecting
um the Integrity with which I hold that
law license no they don't
they simply don't so
um I also wanted to address the issue
that was raised by yourself
representative private schools lad about
private schools and I will remind this
committee that I had the rare uh
opportunity to testify in front of this
committee with Megan Tuttle president of
Nea on this particular Bill and and I
think it's really important to remind
the committee that Nea supported this
bill and it was a pleasure to testify
with Megan Tuttle I wish it happened
more often
um
to be honest with you uh so we did
include and it is the intent of this
bill with my understanding of the intent
of this bill uh which I think was
sponsored by representative Miler to
include private schools
um and the reason we wanted to do that
was because as the department has said
all along
you know child safety issues it's not a
zip code issue
it's it's not a zip code concern I think
everyone on this committee can can agree
to that and the same thought when with
with private schools that if we have an
individual who we are concerned
about the safety of that person around
children
we don't want to take that person out of
the public school realm and say
well you can go to to a non-public
school and teach there
um
you know I rarely testify in my personal
capacity you you all know I rarely say
the word I I refer to the department but
I can tell you that I personally would
not feel comfortable if there was an
educator that I believed was potentially
dangerous around a child saying yeah go
teach in a non-public even saying that I
have chills down my spine I would not
feel comfortable doing that I know from
the Department's perspective
we have limited oversight of dawn Publix
but as a state agency
ethically we would have concerns with
that I share with this committee the
story that I believe I testified to
Prior which was an educator in a public
school here in New Hampshire in the
western part of the state
um was was removed from his job the
superintendent called me was removed
from his job because he wrote A Love
Song to a 13 year old child
that is not illegal that is not criminal
you're not going to find that on a
criminal background check the
superintendent terminated him
slash he resigned one of those
employment mechanisms
and left that District he is no longer
with that District he will never go back
to that District
and I was working with the
superintendent and I simply said to the
superintendent you did everything in
your power and control you did
everything right he is no longer at your
District I have one question for you
what about all the other kids
and she said got it I'll work with you
and she worked with us and we have him
on our suspended list which is public it
is on our website and there's a brief
description about why he's on our our
list
um you can access that list
um and and that's the type of behavior
we want to prevent from going to another
District I'm not comfortable but that
individual was in that District in the
western part of the state and I don't
want it in the other parts of the state
and I wouldn't want it at a non-public
either
further comments or questions to
thank you very much
or was somebody oh represent Tanner just
first of all apologize for breaking in
on different things but I am so involved
in the the safety issue we know that
um and and this bill above all other
bills is really one of the more
important ones this year and I think it
speaks to not only working at a private
school but also as a volunteer and you
know
um these people that uh are in this
category sometimes like to slip between
the cracks and this stuff closes one of
those cracks and at the same time
um
that it's unfortunate that those those
people exist and and have have gone
through this process but at the same
time we do not bismirch the whole
profession of teaching or teachers or
make comments that are not appropriate
so thank you
thank you very much thank you and and my
testimonies never complete without a
question from representative Shanner so
I I appreciate that
um and and if I just may very quickly
I've said this before
this document the code of conduct is
stronger the less we use it as an agency
it really is it really should be
reserved for those very small
very small percentage of individuals who
are who are dangerous around children
and I say that my mom was a New
Hampshire educator and so I think very
highly of Educators and um this
document's stronger the less we use it
appreciate it thank you very much if you
have any other questions I'm in my
Reserve seat in the back of the room
thank you thank you very very much
as usual
um so is there any further discussion on
SB 136 this is a bill which came forward
basically from the Department
it was put forth by Senator Ward and
through you all and we appreciate it
okay any further discussion
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes
Representatives money yes representative
Belcher no
representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative Moffitt yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler yes
representative Heath yes representative
Tanner yes representative luno yes
representative Murray yes representative
grassy yes representative Hall yes
representative Albion yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes
19 days one day
any objections to consent
no okay you'll be on consent
next bill which we have is 213
.
I don't know where you guys interested
Army
now goodbye
um
is
it no no okay
it is
we talked about something
different
yeah but it's called
you use it twice
um
okay
that's fine
this one shall not apply the platforms
thank you
everybody agrees
foreign
line in it from the center
the one I just the first first sentence
yeah that's the way to ride from the
Senate and so this was a
okay
okay we're going to go ahead with uh 213
and before we get to I'll accept any
emotions on that we're gonna have a
brief discussion on that as a total
committee
the the bill as it arrived at our
doorstep here and lines
um
six and seven in it this definition
shall not apply to platforms used for
demonstrating evidence in student career
development
does everybody agree with that
oh okay I was looking probably no I'm
looking at as it was amended by the
Senate
okay line six and seven
good
okay
and then on the amending language which
we discussed last week or wherever the
last time we met there was an added
section to 189 colon 66 under Roman 5
Section f
and it reads A provision that students
participate in career exploration or
Career Technical education May with
written parental consent register for
technology platforms and services to be
used as part of the student's approved
program of study which required the
provision of personally identifiable
information copies of a written of
written parental consent shall be
retained as part of the students
educational record that is what we had
quite a discussion on that portion of it
is there any anybody that doesn't
remember or recall that other than those
like represents that representatives to
stand the end yes representative Hall uh
yes thank you
um the other thing I remember is adding
the word approved for before technology
platforms we had talked about that there
was talk about that having approved in
their choice I agree okay it would be
read registered for Approved technology
platforms and then students approves
program of study I recall that too in
fact I wrote that on one and uh
yeah on that one right there
so now the other section which we had
was a section which was an amendment by
brought forward by represent McDonald
and dealing with concerns for safety of
the students
and
you gotta get back to that one the can
here
oh
I think that was uh it was in that other
amendment I believe it was at 1269 h
McDonald Amendment
yeah
and that read something to the fact that
nothing in this section shall encourage
student involvement in careers as
influencers social media models or
Internet personalities or which
otherwise diminish student safety is
that correct Valerie
okay
so let's open it up to those three areas
right now and see if there's any concern
um why I'm doing it this way if we're
going to do anything with this bill and
moving it forward it's got to be done
today
we're running out of time
and if if it's necessary to get you know
an amendment would approved in it that
I'm sure that could be done but we have
to start thinking about doing that in
the next five minutes or so
because they can take up to an hour to
do this
or the other option is to retain this
bill
and we've got 20 already retained I'm
not inclined to want to do that again
for another bill
so let's have some quick discussion here
represent luno
so thank you Mr chair I think it's
important that we move this bill forward
today and I think it's important for all
the reasons that Jeff beard laid out but
also clearly for students who um who go
to CTE students and
um and can can receive digital
credentials through
platforms like like LinkedIn you know I
I think the amendment that that
chair Ladd has put forward 2007 H is
good except I don't support the um the
the sentence that begins nothing in this
section shall encourage that begins on
the end of line nine it completes
through line 11.
um I don't think it's necessary and um
and it's you know it's one of those
things what other things do we want to
knock out or prevent I mean it's
essentially an unlimited list why are we
limiting it to these and when you start
having a knockout list that limits it to
three things is that saying that
anything that's not on this list is is
therefore uh acceptable or encouraged so
I I would think we're better off uh
leaving it to the Judgment of the local
school boards uh and their approval
curriculum as to whether or not they
want to have careers and influencers
social media models internet
personalities it just seems um
that it would not be necessary in this
uh
in this amendment so I would suggest
just eliminating that line
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair I'd like to respond to that a
little bit considering I wrote that
sentence the list is non-exhaustive
because of the last clause which says or
which otherwise diminished student
safety to respond to what you just said
just because something's not listed does
not mean it's encouraged because again
it says or which otherwise diminishes
student safety again this goes with the
comments of Representative Tanner on the
last bill just a few minutes ago safety
is Paramount and that's what this
sentence
um demonstrates
no no I'm I'm sorry you misinterpreted
what I what I said
um I didn't say that this that this
sentence is is exhaustive
um uh it's it it it's not when you when
you start saying this you can't do this
or you can't do this or you can't do
that what's that saying about other
things that you do not list
um uh in this so so
um I I just don't feel it's that
sentence is necessary
Alexis
yes I object to uh this the sentence in
Part B this definition shall not apply
to platforms used for demonstrating
evidence in student Career Development
because one of the things that that
would then allow is LinkedIn and I got a
call from
rep Ford's wife Mary Ford who works and
has worked with uh
Granite State and I think she's
currently with snow she's done a lot of
work in these areas and she called me
because she was very concerned that we
would be allowing LinkedIn to high
schools they do not do it in her college
and they do not do it because she said
they are very loose with their private
data they you know they are not good at
holding on to private data she suggested
and what they do at the University that
she is at is they have a private
um
I forget what she called it it's a
private organization that takes that
keeps track of all the various
Badges and accreditations and all that
kind of
digital
um and she said there are a number of
them out there and they are they are
very good and very tight with with
holding on to the students data and not
letting it you know their private data
and so that was her big concern and this
is what they do I mean she's they do
this and that that is the policy of her
University and her and of the students
there is they don't do LinkedIn they do
not recommend LinkedIn because LinkedIn
is not secure and that they are much
more secure platforms that are not
social media and so her concern was
allowing social media I mean allowing
LinkedIn into our schools
she's talking in regard to the
university system or that level she's
not talking to high school she's talking
about University but the situation is
the same whether it's University
students private data or high school
students private data and I would say it
was even worse for high school students
because they're not even
adults yet
well with parental consent of
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to follow up a
little bit on that too we we heard
expert testimony and subcommittee we
heard that there is reason to be
concerned about Predator sliding into
direct messages in student social media
um we heard that there is reason to be
concerned about data and security
but the biggest concern I had was that
yes this would in fact Place students
under third party social media terms of
service this would put them under their
speech codes their Association codes and
it just so happens that the LinkedIn
platform because this is colloquial
known as the LinkedIn Bill the LinkedIn
platform just five days ago kicked
presidential candidate Vivek ramaswamy
off their platform for criticizing the
Chinese Communist Party
this is something that we have to take
into consideration is what kind of
speech codes will high school students
now be subject to and we heard expert
testimony to the effect that actually
maybe teachers should be teaching
students how to not say controversial
things online
that's totally goes against the concept
of freedom of speech and I think that
needs to be preserved above all else and
that's why I think this unamended is one
of the most dangerous things we could
possibly be doing to students and I
would be no one anything that doesn't
explicitly remove the possibility of
social media being brought into our
schools
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair so on that
subcommittee uh we heard from Jeff beard
uh Pam McLeod Jeff beard CTE and
um Pam McLeod and her partner Josh or
Justin or something anyway from the
um Concord School District because she's
on the Concord student school district
and she's a data and security specialist
and they agreed the two of them felt
that the original bill
was good that the security data part of
it would should be worked on for about
six months to get that all right so they
were really both supportive of they said
it made us stronger I think I also heard
that they
can use LinkedIn now but that it made it
stronger the original one I have to say
for myself when we
um it was a language that you had
presented chairman Ladd uh that was
developed with attorney Fenton I think
with the approved and the approved and
that seemed to be
fine to me I didn't have a problem with
that but going back to the one right
here on
20078 I would not support that
um I think that I would support what
Jeff beard and Pam McLeod had
recommended from the beginning is to go
with the original language and not do
these amendments
for the representative McDowell thank
you Mr chair since it has been brought
up in respect to the subcommittee they
Jeff beard and um the other speaker as
well they did say that they like the
amendment as well that is 1269 age since
members of the subcommittee address
concerns being Predators online after
looking at it for maybe 10 to 30 seconds
said if we do have a concern as many
committee members and subcommittee
members Express of Online safety
concerns due to Predators online harming
students with social media accounts used
in schools a concern that was addressed
that Amendment 1269 age or similar
language as presented by chairman Ladd
in 2007 H would address that safety
concern that was expressed
further discussion representative
cordelli thank you I I think that the
basic
divide we're hearing is that the
original bill and the amendment that you
just referenced representative McDonald
um
basically exempt
uh platforms for career development from
the social media statutes and social
media account definitions
um
and some have expressed concerns about
social media in general
so I think you know and I also um from
the beginning expressed concerns about
the whole subject of digital badging is
and is um
representative lakis mentioned is in use
at the community college system
I think there are issues with ownership
of the data access and even with
LinkedIn we heard that there was instant
messaging and I think um we we heard
from some on uh in-house testimony that
there is instant messaging available in
LinkedIn and could put
students in instant messaging contact
with
teachers but who knows who else within
the LinkedIn system
um which which might be a concern so
they're
um you know is there a privacy agreement
required for the district to sign with
LinkedIn or whoever the vendor is
um uh I think there are many issues
along those lines that need to be
addressed before
um I'm comfortable with this
um and I know from my research with
digital badging I already mentioned the
ownership of the data but
um in some of these digital badging
systems and I'm not sure about LinkedIn
but
um who can see that data in some of
these digital badging systems the
student can't even see what credentials
are being added so I think there are
many issues
um and I was I think representative Paul
you mentioned that some of those aspects
need to be studied for for months by
people at the subcommittee when they
testified
so I think they're I'm very
uncomfortable with this the way it
stands
one of the things we need to consider
though is in looking at 189 colon 66
Roman 5.
it states each local Education Agency
I.E School Board
shall develop a data and privacy
governance plan which shall be presented
to the school board for review and
approval by June 30th 2019.
then underneath that item C policies and
procedures for access to data and
protection of privacy for students and
staff including acceptable use policy
for applications digital tools and
extensions we're also adding item fifth
F on there too so it seems to me that
there's got to be as in the letter that
I have from Jeff beard here
um this uh see it says section five is
the provision that currently requires
each Lea to develop a data and privacy
governance plan
does that plan now is it now a local
responsibility to develop this process
and therefore what we be doing is just
adding a section F on
allowing the ctes to be involved as long
as there's parental consent and the the
online platform and services relevant to
the students approved program of study
so it looks to me like the school has
you know is overseeing this plan correct
me if I'm mistaken
it represent Milo yeah I think you're I
think you're right uh Rick and I I want
to go back to how this bill came to us
this came to us from the Career and
Technical people who wanted to provide
greater opportunities for kids who can't
get on because of the restrictions of
the school right now and I
and I'm going back to the original but
I'm looking at the original bill at this
thing and it talks about uh Career
Development it talks about technical
education this is dealing with CTE kids
it's not dealing with middle school or
high school kids or perhaps high school
kids uh older ones but
I'm I'm concerned because they brought
this to us so that they could expand the
opportunities for kids in the CTE
programs I mean that's that was my
original understanding for this the
original bill was one in that paragraph
too referenced the wrong area of Statute
is 189.70 rather than 189
and so we corrected that we made that
change so
you know I support the way the bill came
to us with the modification that on
number two we put it in F is which is
reflective of what we we got from the
Department the question I think that we
have in front of us is do we include the
the sentence which is the McDonald
Amendment that's that's the question
yeah thank you Mr chair and Rick I think
you've you've you've summed it up very
well there uh you know I think it would
make sense to see and I would support an
amendment that simply replaces section
two of the bill
with section two as you have in your
Amendment
that would do exactly what you just said
is that correct that's correct okay
but what about the up in section one the
that second sentence there following the
Waters Amendment or the way it came in
from the Senate the second sentence
would be gone the first sentence that
this definition shall not apply is
already in the bill
yeah so it's just replacing what what
you just said is essentially replacing
section two in the bill as it came to us
with section two from your Amendment
yeah
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
I just wanted to clarify the testimony
that we received regarding the um
privacy agreements we heard from the
experts that LinkedIn being owned by the
Microsoft Corporation refused to enter
into an agreement
um therefore the only thing that they
could do to get on to LinkedIn is to
agree to the standard user agreement
which effectively seeds All rights to
the Microsoft Corporation
okay what we need to decide real quickly
here you know before we have any more
discussion on this because we're running
out of time
thank you Mr chair uh in as far as F
goes I know on the on the Fenton
you're not a mandatory approved uh no I
was going to say Jeff you had said at
the Committee hearing the Jeff beard
agreed with this correct he had written
you an email or something we had to
review it by the attorney from the
Department of Education but didn't he
also he was also here
okay yeah thank you
so the question Jennifer uh when are
when's the last moment we can get
something done through
um
OLS today if we were to take a sentence
out of an amendment
so Rick Ricky was the play section two
right
well we've we've got that already if you
look at the Latin Amendment it's all re
it's already in there right which that
Amendment but if you take that sentence
this one
is that second sentence that uh deals
with that's the
McDonald Amendment
you know the thing is that if if we want
to get this thing going
we could go and have this great
discussion a committee a conference
or on the house floor either way
if we could get this done we need to get
it done the way we want it I agree
but what I'd like to find out are if we
go ahead and have something done now do
we have the votes to do it
okay let's do a straw boat right now
those which would be supportive of an
amendment uh if you look at the lab
Amendment right now taking out
line the last sentence there in line 9
10 11.
and
we could if it's time providing we could
work put the word approved in there but
I think that that's it's kind of the
quickest way to do it is just take the
one sentence out and have it like that
so how many people would be supportive
of that Amendment
I mean Mike can you count from I can't
see you in this front
yeah but you see how many I can't attend
oh I'm with you no it's 10 I think
one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen so it's worth getting an
amendment done
okay
for talking about
talk to her yeah
oh yeah
okay but she now based on what happened
yesterday
yeah
they put in a two between two articles
because it's basically missing a chamber
um and Target would be another heart
surgery in September October
and she's you know okay she's basically
having lines
um
foreign
so we don't want to foreign
scheduled
we should have it in about 20 30 minutes
oh
um
welcome to education
okay what we're going to do is we're
going to just uh hold this in advance
right now and we'll come back to it in
about 20-25 minutes
and we have an amendment
so then that takes us through what we're
going to exec today what I'd like to do
is uh we had the 20 bills right there
I'd like to quickly go down through that
list and uh see which bills we can
handle as a committee a whole which we
want to set up as a subcommittee
does everybody have a list of retained
bills and while you should have it on
the calendar there too
it is a copy I've got an extra one right
here that's a copy of the calendar
yeah yeah just you can see them on the
bottom part there on that page
okay the first bill which we have there
is
um we're looking at house bills here uh
HB 147 advisory committee disabilities
this deals with membership
um is that something we can address uh
representative cordelli uh you were
weren't you part of that yes I think
that was my bill
um and it was basically to revised
membership
um the committee I think is uh unwieldy
in terms of the number of participants
um I've uh also talked to the former
house
representative to
um the committee and I talked to the
current representative of Representative
good job who agrees and shared her
insights as to her experience
um this year working on the committee
and so I think the two of us agreed that
we would get together and and review
current membership as well as Federal
Federal Regulations as to who is
required to be members on this committee
because that is in statute federally in
under idea so I believe that we can take
a look at that and bring something back
in the fall to the community the whole
yes
is there any other comment about that
bill I'm rep Santana would like to be in
that community
if we are are we going to make a
subcommittee and that would be the
question or can we have a committee the
whole and have the group bring back some
kind of a proposal for discussion
that's you're not talking about the
subcommittee right right back to the
committee of the whole
any
so would the committee of the whole be
working on
draft language or would it be draft
language that's brought I think we're
just talking about membership on on it
right
right but would we would be would
essentially we'd be starting with the
bill and then discussing whether a draft
Amendment they would bring some draft
material before and then however long it
takes us hope to me the whole to look at
it okay I think there's some very very
important bills coming up in here this
is a committee of membership
which yes it's important but it's it's
not going to
it's not really policy
Mary did you have something
no
are there any other related
bills that would come up at the same
time well let's look down through this
list and see and and if we have to do
something like that we could have you
know Glenn and another individual and
then we could get kadab involved who's
on that particular Association already
uh it should be people throughout food
but if it's just a little work group and
not a so-called bringing back some kind
of draft to the committee that's going
to look at committee the whole
are there any other special edition okay
let's go on down the list the next one
down there is 155 charity
indemnification private post-secondary
so I thought we had a Senate Bill like
that
we did
so do we need to do anything in this no
so okay we can skip that one then and
just deal with it later at Community
hope
um the next one down criminal background
checks 267.
can anybody remember
exactly what this went after
the principle that came in or a
superintendent that came in and talked
about wanting to do background checks on
specific groups of people other than
just that certification was that up at
the North country
oh
uh-huh
maybe it should be on the certification
cycle that every three years
and we also talked about that this is
really isn't this the collective bar it
could be a collective bargaining issue
yeah yeah because talk about individual
group yeah yeah
sure they could
yes I remember that
okay
dry you have your end up
yes it was the golf town that he talked
about that and we did get into the fact
that we would maybe like to tie it into
re-licensing and then we talked about
there are other things that have to do
with background checks that that perhaps
would be included in this wider look at
background checks
is is it should we have a subcommittee
on this or should we do a committee the
whole
I think a subcommittee
okay
I have a note that IT addresses
um staff that's been hired prior to the
law
right
right yeah okay the next one down I put
down the subcommittee uh
hb352 excuse absences mental uh size
Behavioral Health we have a number of
bills here dealing with mental health
yes so why don't we combine all the ones
that have to deal with mental health
into one organ one subcommittee
so that would be this bill right here
three or 151
uh let's see
right 505 yeah 151 352. yeah
okay
so it looks like there's three bills in
there
okay going down to the next one
uh HP 354.
Charter School building no this is one
we do need a subcommittee on because we
want to expand it we're going to discuss
building Aid period as well
and
Mary I wish you were on this committee
or put you on it
isn't there isn't there
it's it was taken out the other day from
hb2 and uh because we work we're not
ready to go there yet so we've got to
look at that whole chat or Charter
School law we gotta also look at school
building eight in terms of if you're a
member of the
J.R whole Amendment
which came up in division two and we
have Amy Clark that says I'd like to
engage she has some good ideas she'd
like to move forward on so there will be
a subcommittee on this one
this is probably one of the more
important subcommittees we will have
okay uh reading assessment and
Intervention Program
was this similar it was dyslexia right
that was my uh larger bill yeah um and I
I've been working on some tweaks and I
hope I can bring that back to the
committee the whole
would you like to have any subcommittee
on that no I don't think it needs it
okay we what where's the status of the
dyslexia bill right now that got passed
that got passed okay so okay so we'll
have a committee the hole in that one
um
439 relative duty to provide education
and contracts with privates I I I don't
have the whole bill in front of me uh or
a title
um 439
and also duty to provide anything
yes it's the one that says repeals the
authority of a school board to execute a
contract with a non-sectarian private
school and also
to extend education until the people's
22 years of age
well we got the edge case through age
222 right I believe he had missed one
spot oh we missed a spot
right okay
okay so do we need a a subcommittee on
that
or is that something we could take care
of within uh committee a whole
I think we ought to be able to do that
it's not going to be like an in-depth
study like building eight
okay maybe a hoe
um we did 505
um 553 information on Personnel salaries
that that was another one of my bills
that required
salaries right and um yeah based on the
testimony that we heard at that point I
will uh tweet the bill and bring it back
remember that's the one word I brought
in the Haverhill annual report and
they're all listed in that
yeah so we'll wait for the committee to
hold and see what you bring forward
okay
um
I think there's another huge topic here
uh special education support financial
support we had a bill where we were
trying to help differentiated Aid that
got torn apart in division two
yeah and uh we had another bill on
catastrophic Aid as well our our special
ed Aid that's where the three and a half
times was reduced down to two and a half
or one and a half uh tremendous
financial implications for that but we
need to work on this so that's a
subcommittee we'll have on that one
loan forgiveness 623 teacher loan
forgiveness program that was serious one
at Mill or one like yours
looked at here
did you mention the higher ed commission
related to Salmon also which one said no
that loan forgiveness I think there was
some discussion about the higher ed
commission looking at that
oh yeah that's right exactly we
The Higher Education commission's
meeting on the fifth I think
and the issues which we're dealing with
well we don't have I don't think loan
forgiveness is on there we have the
Provost coming in from PSU we have Wayne
Jones coming in from the
University system talking about
the issues there of uh enrollments and
um there's one other topics on there now
too
um there's a number of so we're loaded
on the fifth
it's I'm okay with it and if we can get
the people that do it
okay
um
the next one is attendance admr for
school districts and at 6 25 and 6 30 7.
attendance for homeschoolers
so those two could be combined
if we need to have a subcommittee
different
um
yeah 25 and 637.
yeah I think so too and I think they
should be combined
yeah on on those two bills 625 637
looking at the next one down 628
wait a minute women jumped over 627
local education Improvement plans and
disparities in education that's much
like I think representative Moffett
didn't you have something like that
we're
is that is that his bill yeah
where the Improvement for mathematics is
the funding yeah yeah
that's not this one though
uh we're on 620s
genetically
that's my last year
this is something that could be done
quickly through a committee to hold
[Music]
it won't be taken quickly then no
quicker
okay let's take a break from this we got
the amendment back for the other one
okay
so we'll reopen up the exec session for
SB 213 thank you
foreign
so I'll make a motion OTP on Amendment
2061h and represent Miler seconds it
discussion
uh I think we've discussed anybody else
want to discuss it
yes representative
I still think
and we didn't really discuss the issues
of opening students up to social media
in general
and this does allow students to be
opened up to social media
further discussion
I can't hear you sir I'm sorry yeah
that's correct that's that's a correct
reference yeah
the the statutory reference of 189.70 up
top and 189 66 in the second part those
are correct references correct
further discussion
ma'am Clark would you please call the
roll
the Motions OTP made by lad and second
by miler
for this for this amendment you just
handed out for this amendment yes
uh you know we were just in discussion
mode I think oh so we have not made a
motion on the bill well let's do that
I'll make a motion OTP on SB 213.
okay we got it
now I'd like to also make a motion to
amend
uh 213 with
house Amendment 2061
discussion on the amendment
Kirk would you please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative blackis no
representative decimali
yes
represented Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Moffett
no excuse me representative quartz
yellow no representative Miler yes
representative Heath yes
representative Tanner
yes
representative luno
yes representative Murray yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascabin yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes
12 years eight Nays
okay now we need a
um
a vote on the bill as amended
the motion is OTP with 2061h
announcer
Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative lekkas no representative
Simone
yes
representative Belcher
no representative dry no every time a
McDonald no representative Noble nope
representative Moffett
no Representative cortiello no
representative Myler yes representative
Heath yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Murray yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
well 12 years eight knees
okay we'll close that exact session and
get back to the minority will who will
be doing The Minority Report
I would like to Mr chair
okay represent McDonald
okay uh we dropped off on 6 28
or let's see no uh 627 627
um Lea local Education Agency
Improvement plans and disparities in
education do we need to have a
subcommittee or yes
yeah the subs can go now subs don't have
to hang around
okay good all righty
and uh I'm glad to celebrate your
birthday
thank you
[Music]
to you happy birthday dear Mike
happy birthday to you
I won't take any questions thank you
see you later
okay
thank you very much
for technical education
it is what it is hey thank you you're
welcome have a good afternoon the rest
what's left of it now I can go to work
she's going to go to work she was
supposed to be at work uh
okay thank you very much thank you 6 27.
relative location education Improvement
plans disparities in education
what do you think uh
can we can we deal with that in a
committee of the whole
is it necessary to have a in-depth
okay committee the whole
okay
in 628 we got or no wait a minute I'll
accept
except funds perform background checks
for employees involved can we put that
up with the other one
did with a criminal background checks
yeah okay
then 651 schools may use Transportation
networks I think that was yours
represent
um cordelli remember the uh yes the Uber
or whatever it was right Uber like yeah
um yes we're waiting on there's a at
least two uh Transportation companies
um similar
um methods of operation
um they're uh the one is working with
the department now a department of
safety and the other one that I'm in
contact with is working on legislation
in Illinois that might be a blueprint
for what we do here so I will bring
those the results of those back to the
committee of the whole okay okay
Committee of home okay
and
SB 25
Charter School payments
repealing
yes
it was a house bill it was a house bill
I'm not sure what happened to it in the
Senate
it's eliminating those quarterly reports
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so we don't need it we can just
committee hold that then
yeah that's kind of combining that's
what 625 okay
and we did uh 150 we wanted to see
Senate Bill 151 that's what the other
Mental Health
and so I think that takes care of
how we'll handle it we'll have those Sim
uh committee uh subcommittees which I
will then
ask representative will there be two or
three members and I'm going to have him
assign the Democrats to it and I will
assign the Republicans to the
subcommittee
yeah
218 and 266. I need to hear those didn't
we
no we didn't I think we're waiting until
they came here waiting to see how the
Titan II funds could be used for that
yeah that's right we have it was Melissa
we're going to work with doe on that we
were working with doe on that
yeah so I think that'd be a committee
the whole it's a whole group and then
um Statewide Improvement and Assessment
program
and that is a mountain of job
quite frankly I think that's so large
that we'll be lucky to get that thing
done
um
is there anybody here wants to spend a
lot of time on 266 this summer and fall
uh no
okay that's a committee of the whole and
it's something where if anybody wants to
look through some of this stuff bring
your ideas to the committee of the whole
um it's it's
yeah yeah we we sort of can I don't
think we've taken action or anything
we have
commentary
we didn't get through it all though
we didn't finish the last several pages
in that report we got from Jen
so
this question
please yeah all right
I think that to do this we're going to
have to spend some time with Caitlin and
Nate green
and I think a lot of it's tied up to the
federal application for Acer Monies
if anybody wants to get engaged in that
further no
it's a long session that makes it even
longer
um so we'll we'll get we'll get more
information from them so when we do have
the committee the whole we can scoot
through it as quickly but I don't I'm
not holding my breath on that
foreign
sex is a different cat this is combining
the adequacy and the delivery of
adequacy and all 193 sections and it's
trying to stop the repetition and then
try to make it easier to read I don't
know if it's doing that
it's very confusing
this is the type of thing you have to
hire a contractor to do and give them
about two years to do it
yeah has anybody been to the 306
hearings I was going to go to one up New
London here
okay
so what we'll do is I'll work with
representative miler in getting the
names of people for subcommittees is
there any subcommittee that somebody
would like to be on
really
Balboni representative Balboni
the mental health one Mental Health
okay
yeah let's get all the stuff for me to
do yeah yeah so I think what what your
your uh representative Myler will do is
he'll just contact his caucus
and and determine and he'll probably be
asking that type of a question to you
okay not do the same thing with the
Republicans that way we can scoot out of
here
um the only other thing which we had
down well we had the committee
conference and what I'm going to do is
we have some side by sides for the four
bills
look them over we can only recommend to
concur non-concur or recommend a
committee conference
yet
I I do have the side by sides right here
so I can give you copies
so before you head out of here come on
up here and get
one of each
and then what I will do is I will
contact you by the web
trying to find out where the individuals
are this way we've done a lot of times
in the past sometimes we meet prior to
session or after session in a corner of
the hall
and go through it quickly
um
there's several ways of doing it some
chairs do it themselves
okay
so I got the these reports right here
I'll put all four of them
right here in front of where
representative Ford usually sets some
cardiola
okay
or if I just take one on the way out
next week
yeah and what's
anybody interested in knowing where we
are in the finance stuff yeah
okay
we have uh
senate had a exact session and with fine
the finance uh
on Friday last week
and in that they did not take hb2 our
recommendation
they are rewriting it the base cost is
at forty one hundred dollars
then they're taking that amount and
throwing it over on the other side of
the column in the education
extraordinary needs Grant which is based
upon extraordinary needs based on Prop
but F and R qualifiers the number gives
is based on F and R not on your total
population of your school
stabilization is also uh eliminated over
a period of ratcheting that's it four or
five years I think it's five years it
ratchets down the way they do that is
they have a hold harmless which they're
starting back in 2009 we had to hold RMS
but it was a very small amount of money
about 20 27 28 million dollars
this whole harmless is 63 million
dollars
and it was lower when they first came
around 50 million dollars but uh
the
Senate was informed that by doing what
they're doing with only 50 million
dollars there
the property poor towns
were really low much lower than they
were with our HP
to proposal
so then they took
that difference there about what 13
million roughly and put that into hold
harmless and it UPS it a little bit for
the property poor towns initially
the city of Manchester in the first
Senate proposal received 27 million
dollars addition to what they would have
received
from current law
um we we uh
we objected to that seeing that the
property poor towns were not getting
hardly anything they were whole they
weren't losing but they're very close to
the current level of funding
and so with that we
um convinced them to go to instead of a
102 of them of the whole house went 104
percent
so it went four percent up
and it took that 13 million dollars and
slugged it in there that's where we
stand right now
100 100
it was what 150 million plus dollars 156
million bucks
five percent overall
about five years I think no immediately
it's immediate but there's oh yeah
they're reducing slowly the whole
harmless which pumps back into the
formula which hold harmless reduces over
a decade yeah yeah per biennial
it's over 10 years
full stabilization
no we have not touched stabilization
stabilization took a tip
years ago and was restored four years
ago or six years yeah
um back to 100 in 2012 numbers right
yeah and so the Senate proposal will be
to eliminate stabilization starting in
FY 24 and and that
two new components extraordinary needs
Grant which um which is more generously
funded than the current extraordinary in
each screen is that an old harmless to
bring
everybody back up if if you were below
your your current FY 24 estimate that
came out in October
um then um then it would bring you up to
102 uh and I think now 104 of what that
estimate was so so for most towns like
well let me say another way or for for
cities like Manchester and Nashua that
have a high number
a high number of both pre-introduced
price lunch students and um and and uh
and less than um
I think it's
it's uh less than six million or 6.6
million dollars evaluation per free
reduced price lunch student they uh they
get a substantial additional Grant so it
so Manchester Nashua who
you know at least according to all our
work you know need need additional
support from the state but um but places
like Berlin and Claremont and dairy
um would get basically four percent more
than they're currently getting and
that's exactly what what um what the
current Senate plan is doing
um
yeah in the uh
Berlin currently
gets a little over 11 million dollars
and then yeah under the uh Amendment
from the Senate you would get 11.5
million dollars right
under under the house Amendment you've
gotten a little over 12 million dollars
so if they're that's the the two cities
which kind of take it in the shorts
Berlin and Franklin
Claremont Mr Claremont yep
Pittsfield Newport
yes yes yes say that again the laws of
stabilization
yes yes yes yes yeah and and yeah so the
loss of stabilization is about 106 156
million dollars to make up for that
difference is this
extraordinary needs Grant which doesn't
hit every place that stabilization hit
and this hold harmless the whole
harmless is now what over 60 million
dollars 63 63 million dollars and so
that gets you back up to um to
essentially back places like Berlin back
to par
you know some of the towns which you
know some of those towns like a Hanover
they increase
uh
so that's that's where we stand on it
very increase can't over some of the
um well
um
centipede not so much because they're
also a an excess left down but Hanover
not being an excess swept home and not
be a stabilization tone is going to see
an increase due to the increase in base
so the the increase in base does not
help the property poor communities like
Berlin and Claremont and it doesn't help
the property rich communities because of
the excess Sweat Right yeah so it does a
little bit for
some folks in the middle
yeah
we're not there no but uh
the amount of money we're spending right
on current law for educations
962.4 million dollars
um the house proposed 1 billion 31
million
and the Senate is proposing
legally important one
for FY 24
billion 40 million
so they're proposing nine million more
than we proposed
didn't they put some of the programs
back into the educational Festival
yes they they did do that yeah I I do
have that here they put most of the
programs all back into the education
trust fund what they didn't do though is
they didn't fund the tuition and
transportation for for Career Technical
education it's back to nine million
dollars per year of the biennium
and we'd recommended 11.2 million per by
any due to the fact that
we see now that we have 10th 11th and
12th graders going to ctes Nashua Exeter
and Manchester transportation is now
covered by two before they they
transport inside their own district and
if you didn't transfer outside the
district you didn't get Transportation
money
so with that added in there with the
cost those three communities that alone
jumps a huge amount
but remember the out of that nine
million dollars first comes
Transportation what's left is then
divvied up for tuition reimbursement to
the sending District based on 75 percent
for the sending for the state and and 25
percent of the cost for the local but
with more students involved it's going
to be less tuition
and so there's why we asked for the 2.2
additional
it was actually voted down rejected due
to maintenance of effort maintenance of
effort means that once you get to a
level of funding you can't go backwards
and but that's not the way it's always
been done around this joint if going
back about six seven eight years ago it
used to be five million dollars for
Career Technical education we jumped at
the nine
knowing that due to our population that
we have we're trying to get increased
CTE population we got apparel that with
supporting dollars and
we have just decided by way of that
Amendment not to do that
and that's going to be very difficult
for our CTE centers to function the end
of it keep current and to get new
students yeah
and they won't have the seats and some
ascending districts aren't sending
because they don't get the
transportation dollars so what do we
need on that Rick to get it to get it to
where where it was where I left the
house we need another 2.2 million
dollars each year of the biennium it's
another five so 4.4 yeah 4.4 million
dollars
um
I heard from Senator Lang he's going to
try to put a floor in them and then
supporting that 4.4 yeah yeah however
yeah and I mean
honestly there's not much difference
between one you know 1 billion 31
million and 1 billion 40 million when it
comes to um adequacy yeah um I mean it
it that nine million dollars doesn't do
that much you know spread across
um and and I think both those numbers
the one that passed the house and the
one that's being proposed in the Senate
are both strong numbers but but you'd
probably get more bang for the buck if
you took 4.4 out of that and put it
towards CTE yeah
um you know directed it towards CTE and
then looked at a at a at a more
um
in an allocation
of adequacy that was more along the
lines of the house formula which
wouldn't quite be as generous for
Manchester and Nashua but it but it
would still be generous for Manchester
and Nashua but also really help out
places like Berlin and Claremont
Franklin Pittsfield
um that have been taking it on the chin
for way two one so
the actual cost for the state to send to
a CT Senate it's about 680 000. that's
funding at 10 cents per mile per pupil
that rides the bus
which is ridiculous to begin with the
the that's not the actual that's what
the state pays for the actual cost is
2.8 million dollars per year
so the the districts is subtract 680 000
on the 2.8 you come up pretty close to
2.2
and that's where it's all coming from
but right now what that transportation
is going to do it's going to take away
from tuition
and we're just trying to make the same
amount of dollar
spread out further
it's like we do what catastrophic AIDS
sometimes
all right great
don't forget